では よろしくお願いします
二十四ですか  二十四です
はぁ これ難しい  どう  [笑い] 候補はあります
単純ではありません エワンメー・スタン・エカン・サミャン・バガワー・ラージャ・ガヒリ・ヒレティ・ヴェーリワニ・カランダキニ・ワーテ
お釈迦様が あの 祝福小寺で住んでいた時の話なんです
ア
タコ・サンバフラ・ジャーティ・ブーマ・カー・ビクク・ジャーティ・ブーミャン・ワッサン・ウッタ・イエナ・バガワタ・テーナ・ウパサンカミン・スー・ウパサンカ
ミットワ・バガワン・タン・アビワディットワ・エーカ・マンタン・ニシーディン・スー
このジャーティブーミという場所でしょうね
で で ジャーティブーミというところに住んでいた比丘たちが
あの  雨期に入って 雨期終わってからお釈迦様のところに行ってお釈迦様に挨拶しましたと
このジャーティブーミっていうのは生まれた
いわゆる故郷 故郷という意味なんです
そこで故郷に住んでいる比丘たちが故郷で雨期に入ってというと
なんとなくあまりもわからなくなるんですね
そこで あの こちらでは
このパーリ語では 仏典では
まあ国境といえば このどこでもないんだよと
あれこれって場所ではないんだと
これは釈尊が生まれた場所だと
だから国境というのはお釈迦様が生まれた場所
ですから この釈族のお坊さんたちっていう話になるんです
だからお釈迦様の田舎
生まれたところ そこにも生まれた場所という
あの 固有名詞で使うと
お釈迦様が生まれた場所を意味するんだよと
で 我々にとってはジャーティ
ジャーティブーミは山口ですよとかね
まあ京都ですよとかね
もう新潟ですよとか言えますけど
そこはなくて じゃあパーリ経典でジャーティブーミといえば
まあお釈迦様が生まれた場所で
故郷で で そちらのの比丘たちですから
おそらく釈族か そこらの他の住民かですね
で その場所で雨期に入って
雨期終わって 雨期っていうのは三ヶ月間ですね
今雨期の時期なんです
入ってないのは私ですけど
[笑い] で あと一ヶ月間ですね
エーカ・マンタ・ニシンネ・コーテー・ビクク・バガワタ・バガワ・エータダ・ウォーチャ
そこで比丘たちがお釈迦様礼をして傍らに座ったところでお釈迦様がこんなことを教えます
キンヌコー・ビッカヴェ・ジャーティ・ブーミャン・ジャーティ・ブーマ・カーナン・ブー・ビククーナン・サブラフマチャーリーナン・エワン・サン・バーヴィト
えーと どうですか あなた方はこのジャーティブーミ
田舎に住んでる 田舎と言ったらおかしいんですね
故郷に住んでるあんた方は
そのあなた方同業者同士でこういう風なことを考えているんですかと
エワン・サン・バーヴィト
こういうことを実践して
あの プラクティスしているんでしょうかと
習ってるんですかと こんなこと
一番目はアッタナーチャ・アッピッチョ・アッピッチャカタンチャ
うーん ビククーナン・カッタ
アッタナ 自分自身でアッピッチョ
アッピッチョっていうのは小欲ですね
あの希望は少ない 小さい
で 希望は小さいって言っちゃおかしいね
[笑い] あまり大量にあれこれという限りのない希望があるわけじゃないんですね
適切な希望で アッピッチャカタンチャ・ビククーナン・カッタ
これが比丘たちにもそれを教えるという意味でしょうかね
日本訳はどう訳していますかね
お話を 話をしていますか
ちょっとカタッタでなければおかしいんですけど
なんでカッタになってるんですかね
ああ そうかね  ん？ カッタリーのことでしょうか
まあカッタっていうのはしたということなんですけどね
いわゆる カッタで出ますけど
カタッタだったら語らで喋るということになるし
で ブッダゴーサ長老はそれについて何考えてるんでしょうかとわからないし
まあとにかく あの 自分ですごいアッピッチャでいる
このアッピッチャっていうのは仏教では大変な意味のある言葉なんです
アッピッチャは日本語では小欲と訳しますけど
これ単純なことではないんです
これが人間が堕落する
反対はマヒッチャタというんですね
多欲があること あまり限りのない欲望
希望 期待があると 人間はそれで壊れてしまうんですね
で 仏教での人間っていうのは
やっぱり能力には切りがある
できることには切りがある
で どうしたっても生命っていうのは小さな存在なんですよ
それで小さな存在が欲望だけ無限大に広げると
もう壊れてしまうんですね
それ自体はすごい悪で見ているんですよ
マヒッチャタという多欲は
多欲自体は悪 精神的に落ち着かない
自分にも他人にも迷惑
それでしっかり自分自身を育ててしっかりするためには
コントロールできる必要な欲求の中で自分を治めなくちゃいけないんですね
だから成功する人間っていうのは
自分には何が必要でしょうかと
このどうしても必要な欲求だけ
それを控えていて 私にはこれが必要です
これなくては生きていられないという
このどうしても生きるために必要なものに限っちゃうんですよ
で そういうふうに精神的なコントロールできることが
仏道においては大変大事なことなんです
ですから このアッピッチャタっていうのはものすごい大変な道徳なんです
小欲っていうことは で
俗世間の例で言えば あの服を買いたいと
思ったらもう管理不可能なんですよ
買いたいではなくて その服が私に必ずも必要ですかと
それなくては物事うまくいかないんですかと
それで あ これがないとやっぱり人生はうまくいくわけじゃない
いろいろトラブルが起こる
だから必ずもこれ必要だよとわかったところで
それに欲求をつけてもいいんですよ
ですから この人間失敗するのは
それで見る見るもの欲しがる
きくきくもの欲しがる
それではもう生きることはできなくなっちゃうんですね
ではなくて どうしてもこれでこれがないと生きていられない
そこら辺で我々はちゃんとガイドつけて
そこで印をつけておけば
それ以上はいかないんだよというと
すごく安全に生きていられる
精神的にはずっと丈夫です
そういうことでアッピッあなた方はアッピッチャタですかと
それでアッピッチャタについてよく語る人々ですかと
アッピッチャタについて語ると
どういうことですかね
それまたそういう分頭が良くなるんですよ
なぜかというと 小欲について語ったり
説法したり アドバイスしたりする人が何を語るべきかというと
人生に何が必要ですかと語らなくちゃ
生きるということはどういうことですかと
それを語らなくちゃいけないんですね
人間に家が必要ですかと
では宮殿はどうですかっていう話なんですね
家が必要ですけど 宮殿は必要っていうことになりませんね
せっかく家が作るんだったら
宮殿みたいに家が作れそうと思っちゃうと
もう世界それだけで破壊されてしまうでしょうね
お金もない人が宮殿作ろうと
まず土台だけ作ったら土台も借金で作るということになるでしょうね
それから壁はどうしますかと
それで人生が何ともなくなっちゃう
それでちょっとハッとして
はっと作って 建てて 死ぬまで生活することになっちゃうんです
それじゃなくて 自分で考えて
家が必要だから じゃあ二部屋の家が我々
私たちの人生には十分だと思ったら
ちゃんとして家を建てられるでしょうに
だからこのアッピチタについて語るっていうことは
人生について語ることなんです
それは世の中でしないんだから
世の中は狂ってるんですよ
だから仏教は推薦するのは生きるっていうことはどういうこと？生きるために何が必要でしょうかと
はっきり具体的に語り
語りなさいよと 具体的に
例えばみんな みんな買ってるんだから
みんなパソコン買うでしょ
みんな買ってるんだから
みんな携帯買うでしょ
そういうのはもう乱れた世界で
もう混乱の世界での生き方なんですね
パソコンなんか買うなよという話じゃないんです
自分にとってはやっぱりこれがないと
あれこれやと不便だよと
仕事にいろいろ障りがあるんだよと
ものすごく時間無駄になっちゃうんだよと
そうなると パソコンに払うお金が自分に戻っているはずなんです
あの人は買ったんだから
じゃあ私も買っちゃうそうと言っちゃうと
そのお金が行っただけなんですよ
返ってこないんですよ
それで生活はもう乱れちゃうんですね
だから必ず必要なものを買うと
そのお金がなくならないんですね
戻っているんです で そういうことだからアッピチタ小欲について語るということも
人間そつなくしなくちゃいけない
テレビ番組であろうが
ラジオ番組であろうが
普通の日常でお茶飲みながら雑談する時であろうが
アッピチタについて語るべきなんですよ
ものすごいしっかりした話になるんです
この世の中で新しくこういう品物が今出回っているんだよと
あれがこれこれでいいと
いいとは言ってるんですけど
実際はね そんなことは我々には必要でしょうかとかね
それなくて生活できないんでしょうかとかね
そういうふうに語ると
かなり頭が良くなります
だから この仏教の道徳の素晴らしいところはそういうところなんです
で 頭がなければ実践できない
かなり理解能力がないと道徳的な生き方はできない
だから小欲っていうのは自分の人生をちゃんと把握していないと
例えば 子供 3人がいる家族はどれぐらいの大きさの炊飯器を買うべきかということなんですよ
すっごいごっついかっこいいんだからって
2合しか炊けない 炊飯器買ってもね
お金の無駄でしょ それでまあどうせ買うならもうちょっと 5,000円払ってね
もっとでっかいものを買いましょうと言ったら
もう例えば 10人分ぐらいご飯炊ける炊飯器買ったら
それもっとお金無駄遣いですよ
場所も取るわ 電気代も取るわ
しかし自分が半分しかその炊飯器でご飯炊けないわ
あるいはせっかく大きいものを買ったんだから
もう3人分じゃなくて
じゃあ明日の分までご飯炊きません
炊いちゃうと古いご飯食べる羽目になるわ
だから全部無駄なんですよ
だからそういう小欲の人は
家に 3人も子供3人もいるんだから
大人2人で5人分でご飯炊ける炊飯器を選んで買う
そうするとその機械は十分使ってる
ちゃんと使ってるんだから
それ寿命も持ちます ちゃんと毎日使って手入れしているんだから
その機械の寿命持ちます
仕事してくれるんだから
お金がなくなったわけじゃない
そういうことで この小欲の生き方っていうのは
すごく知恵に基づいた素晴らしい生き方なんです
それについて語ると 他人にも役に立ちます
自分の人生もいつでも観察することになります
そこで結構人生は管理できるようになります
だから出家した人々も
これは必ずしもやらなくちゃいけないこと
これやらないと出家が乱れるんですよ
仏教の世界でも結構どんどん乱れていったかというと
もうまあどうせ作るならばでっかく作りましょうという思考でいっちゃうんですよ
そこで管理できなくなっちゃうんですね
スリランカに仏教伝来した時は
王様がもうやっぱりお坊さんたちの儀式でやるために戒壇作らなくちゃいけないと
戒壇というのは土地を境界線を設けるんですね
この王様がどうせやるんだったらね
もう大事な仏教でしょうし
まあとにかく国教にしたいし
王様が仏教徒になったんだからね
自分が住んでる街そのものを戒壇の境界線にしたんです
それで象に鋤をつけて
わざと作って 象は別に田んぼの仕事をするわけじゃないんだけど
で もうアヌラーダプラという町そのものを全部一回りさせて戒壇の印をつけちゃったんです
だから 町全体に仏教の寺になってしまったんです
その中で王様が宮殿を造って生活しなくちゃいけない
お茶々なんですよ で そこで戒律上では
そういう大きな戒壇で儀式儀礼やる場合はすごく難しい
それが特別な戒律いろいろあるんです
いわゆる一箇所で別々で布薩儀式やってはいけないとかね
それいとも簡単にそう送っちゃうんですよ
このお寺でやったって
あのお寺でやったって
どちらでも戒壇の境界の中でしょ
それで結構距離があるんだから
じゃあこちらにいるところで
で こちらでやりましょうと
となるんだから それで大変管理できなかったんです
で 布薩の日でっていうのは
この満月と新月なんですね
全部お坊さんたちが一箇所に集まらなくちゃいけない
それで街全体歩き回って
みんなその時間で集めなさいと言うと
車とかなんともないでしょ
歩いて行かなくちゃいけないし
それでみんな集まるためにバカでかい建物を造らなくちゃいけなくなっちゃったんです
今もそういう跡がありますからね
かなりでっかい建物を作って
そこでもうもうもう千人とか人とかね
三千人とかお坊さんたちを集めて戒壇儀式やったり
戒壇儀式じゃなくて布薩儀式やったりとかね
やっぱりこの せっかく作るんだからでっかく作ろうという思考はあまり仏教的じゃないんですよ
今はもう全部潰れちゃって
どうなってるかわからない
誰もわからない この戒壇の境界線
どこにあるかっていうことさえも
だから新しくこの戒壇開場するという儀式を作ることになったんです
新しいどこかで戒壇みたいな
このお坊さんたちの儀式をやる場所を決める場合は
前もって開場の奉仕を行うんです
ここら辺にある会場は皆大教官は教会は開場しますと
その時はかなり大きく人の土地まで取って
教会線を作って この中全部解除しますという儀式を行ってから
自分たちの小さな場所でまた教会目印をつけながら階段を設定する儀式やるんです
で 設定する儀式も解除する儀式も結構また難しくてややこしくて
だからもう最初からスリランカでもそういう
もう性欲ということからちょっと脱線しちゃって
結構苦しい目にあったというね
だから例えばただ単に大きなお寺作っても
それ維持管理できないでしょうに
大きい大きいお寺作ってはいけないというわけじゃないんです
それぐらいお坊さんたちもいて
維持してくれる信者さんもたくさんいて
それだったら人数が多いんだから
人数を入る分ぐらいは大きく作ってもよろしいし
だからいつでもこのコンパクトで生活しましょうと
というのは仏教の基本的な決まりなんです
コンパクトで生活するとかなり楽
ものすごく楽なんです
そういうわけでお釈迦様が比丘たちにはこの三衣というね
衣三つと鉢と水くしとか
このいくつかしか所有物は持ってはいけないと
それがどうしても必要
衣がどうしても必要です
だからといって三着 四着とかはダメ
一着だけで一着には三枚入っている
で 箪笥まで買ってきて
この箪笥四つありますよと
私の衣です 全部とかね
これは日曜日 これが月曜日とかね
それがやってはいけないんです
そうすると維持管理の問題っていうのは出てくる
そこで食べ物についても
だから出家儀式を行ってすぐその四つを教えてくれるんですよ
アッピチャターの法則を
出家したあなたは 鉢に人が入れたもので満足しなさいよと
自分の鉢の中に人が入れたもので満足しなさい
もし誰かがわざと料理作ってくれたならば
それは特別 特別に恵まれたと思いなさいと
もし信者さんが招待したならば
あれはもう特別の特別だよと
毎日信者さんに招待されてご飯をもらうっていうことは
もう期待してはいけない
ただ 鉢に誰かが入れた一匙のご飯でも
あ 今日はご飯もらいました
これで十分だというふうに思わなくちゃいけない
衣の場合は どこかで捨てている何か服でもね
拾って衣を作れればそれで十分やと
誰か捨てたもの もし信者さんがちゃんとした衣寄付した
布施するとなったら それが特別やと
それは特別に恵まれたことやとお思いくださいと
そういう薬の場合はこの牛の尿ですね
それだけあれば十分やと
もし誰かから薬もらったら
これ特別な特別に恵まれたと思いなさいよと
なんか付いてるんだと
そう思っちゃうと お坊さんたちは毎日付いてるんだという喜びで生きていられるでしょうに
別に一人も牛の尿を飲んで病気治したケースはないんだから
だから最低限をセットしておくと毎日楽しいんですよ
バファリン二つもらっただけでも
もらったんじゃないんですかと
それ楽しいんですよ だと言って日本でもじゃあ牛の尿で頑張るとか
牛の尿を探すためにバファリン入れますか？これまた
バファリンは簡単で手に入るんだけど
牛の尿を手に入るためには新幹線に乗っていかない
それをアッピチャターの原理です
注釈書でもずっと延々と長く長く説明してやります
次 アッタナーチェ サントゥットゥ サントゥッティ カタンチェ カタッタ ビックーナン カタッタ
アッタナーチェ サントゥットゥ
自分が サントゥッティというのは満足ですね
自分がすごい満足して生活する
あれ文句言わない 自分得られているもので十分満足する
そういうちょっとした見方というか考え方なんですね
すごい幸せな人々いるんですね
この幸せな人々を見ると
そういう人々はすごい満足してるんですよ
それ簡単に満足してする人っていうのは簡単に幸せになっちゃうんです
ちょっとしたことをもらって
これで思い存分満足して喜んじゃうと
あげた側にもなんかもうもっとあげた方が良かったんではないかと思ってしまうんですね
なんだこれっぽっちかと思ったら
もうもらうものもらわなくなっちゃうんですよ
それでみんなこんな給料で生活できるわけじゃないんだとかね
いつでも不安ばっかし言ってるでしょ
それはもう確実に不幸になる人々なんです
いくら頑張っても無駄です
その努力は だから自分が得るものについては
やっぱり思い存分満足しなくちゃいけない
いつでもこれで良かったと
そう思う人はもうずっと幸せ幸せで生きていられる
それも精神的に落ち着くためにとっても必ずも必要なものなんです
パーリ語でサントゥティというんですね
それがないとイライライライライライラするんですよ
それでイライラするっていうこと
すごい怒りなんですよ
怒りは破壊的な結果出すんですよ
だから全部壊れてしまうんです
ご飯におにぎり個やと
まあこれっぽっちですかね
ご飯にと思っちゃうと
その人はそれで自分の不幸の種をもう作ってるんです
引き金を引きちゃったんです
不幸の引き金を だからおにぎり個だけでも
ああおにぎり個あるんだ
これで大丈夫やというふうに思わないと
人からもらったらまあ半分でも良かったのにと
という本気で思わなくちゃいけないんですよ
半分でも良かったのに
その個もらっちゃって
そう思う人はいつでも満たして生きていられます
それはちょっとしたごまかしじゃないんですよ
物質的にも その人の人生はいつでも満たしていくんですよ
溢れていくんです だから基本は精神的な状態
精神的にはいつでもそういう電車に乗ったところで
もう全部満員で 今日は満員で本当に座る場所もないんだと思う人は不幸です
やっと乗られたと 満員電車なのに
だからその場合は乗られた
乗られただけで満足してもらわないと
その旅は不幸になってしまうんですよ
旅出たって言うでしょ
文句 今日はもう来たんだけど
もう来なかった方が良かったと思いましたと
満員電車でもうぎゅうぎゅう詰めでヘトヘト疲れたんだよとかいうと
もう旅の目的に達するわけじゃないでしょうに
そういうことで サントゥッティというニバンに
アッタナ・パヴィヴィットゥ・パヴィヴィエカカタンチャ・ビククーナンカタッター
で まあこれから世俗的な世界からどんどん離れていきます
これは比丘たちに話した説法だから
これあまりにも離れますよ
経典の終わりになってくると
だからこれ難しいんです
最初からそんな調子で始まりますからので
最後になってくると もう普通の人々の世界とはもう信じられないほどかけ離れていくんです
だから表面的に読んで軽々しいと思っても
ちゃんと読んでみると
後でやめたほうがよかったんではないかなと思うか
ブッダの教えはね あまりなめたらあかんというか
一行ですごいことを語るんだからね
この世の中の人間にはたったサントゥッティアピッチタというたった一言葉で十分ですよ
この世の中を良くするためには
この世界全部 たった一言アピッチタ小欲
それだけでも十分です
だからそれぐらい人間の真理
生き方を把握して 一言葉にまとめてみせるという
これはブッダ以外誰にもできません
イエス様なんかはもう神
神 神10人連れてきたってできません
大量に聖書を全部読んでも
ヴェーダ聖典はもう10年かけて読み読み終わって 10
年でも読めないぐらい大きいんだからね
ヴェーダ聖典は読めますけど
またブラフマも読まなくちゃあかんだからね 10
年ででも読めない 読んでもこういう生きる真理はない
だからブッダの教えは宝物そのものだというのはそういうわけで
もう宝そのもの 何もやることはないんです
そのものに価値が全部あります
だから完全に語るというね
ソアーカートゥ・バガターダンマ
ものすごく語れているんだと
完璧やというのは この一言なりでも
もう何も残らず全部喋っている
人間に必要なもの それで2番目はサントゥッティ終わっちゃって
3番目はパヴィヴィッタ
パヴィヴィッタからはやっぱり出家の世界に入りますけど
パヴィヴィッタっていうのは離れて生活するって意味なんですね
日本語はどうなってます？パヴィヴィッタは
オンリ これ在家生活と比べてみると
オンリっていう言葉の意味がわかります
在家っていうのは やっぱり奥さんがいなくては
子供がいなくては 使用人がいなくてはとかね
もうあれこれやともうなんとか言い訳つけて
もうなんとか関係作る
車がなければ 家がなければ
別荘がなければ 家にスイミングプールがなければとかね
テニスコートなければとか
それで自分が幸福になるんだぞと思ってるんです
いわゆる付け加えることによって
だから普通の在家生活っていうのは
裸で何も持たないで生まれた一人一匹の人間が
それでいろいろ付けてもらう
つけてつけてつけてつけて
そこで人はどこにいるかわからなくなっちゃうんです
つけたものばっかしで
何か付ければつけるほど
その人の自由がなくなっちゃうんですよ
ある一人の人に家一軒つけてあげる
それでその人を住むとそちらに住まなくちゃあかんでしょうに
それであんたは死ぬまでこちらから離れてはいけないという
終身刑になるんですよ
一人で寂しいと では結婚しましょうと
おめえなんともめでたいことですかと
みんな鶴の絵柄入ってる電報まで打ったりして
で その人はね どんな嫌なことをあっても
あの人と一生ずっと 我慢辛抱しながら生活しなくちゃいけないんですよ
終身刑ですね そこでまたやっぱり子供がいなかったら
いなかったら子供が現れてくるともっとひどい状態になる
逃げたくても逃げられなくなっちゃうんです
夫婦は離婚すればもうなんとかもうもう体からでも逃げられますけど
それでも精神的なもう恨みはそれでもあるんだから
子供が出たらどうですか？どこに逃げるんですかね
で 人間というのは幸せというのはそうやって付け加える
自分に何か一つ引っかかってもらう
それであまりにもたくさん引っかかって
俺が偉そうと言ったりもする
それは仏教は簡単に馬鹿ではないかと
自分がいかに苦しむかということしか考えてないんではないかと
いかに苦しみかということを考えて
その方向へ行動して 幸せだ幸せだと
またすごい もうみんなに大きい声で言ったりもする
だから大恥なんですよ
仏教から言えば 昨日勉強で言ったような
このまるっきり目が見えない人がね
あの誰かに騙されちゃって
その目が見えない人が聞いたことがあります
この白い服っていうのはなんて美しいですかと
あまりにも人々が白い服ってなんて美しいですかと聞いたところで
この人も欲しがるんです
白い服があれば自分も幸せだと欲しがって探す時
あるインチキ人が詐欺師がこの人にものすごく汚い
もう汚れて汚れて油で汚れて墨やら灰やら吸いちゃって
油と灰と一緒にすいちゃうと洗ってももう抜けないしね
そういう服をあげるんですよ
これが真っ白い服だと
純白で綺麗な服だと 美しいだと
目が見えないんだから
その人はそれはやってもらったと
ものすごいかっこいい服をやってもらった
それ着て自慢する なんてかっこいいんですかと
私は 目が見えないんですね
それでも見る見る人から見ればもう笑いが止まらないほどおかしいんですよ
だから世の中の生き方はそういう生き方であると
みんな何か付け加えることで幸福だと思う ２
部屋の家にもう１部屋つなげれば
あーよかったよかったと
その生き方っていうのは
不幸を増える増えるだけ
自由がなくなる生き方であって
苦しみが増える生き方であると
正しい自由な生き方っていうのは
付け加えることではなくて
付けたものを外すんです
付けているものはどんどんどんどん外していく
最後に心にあるこのつけたいつけたいという期待感も外しておく
それが解脱ってことなんです
そこでパヴィリット オンリって何なのかというと
まあ家族やら財産やら
そういう五欲ですね 五欲というんですね
見るもの 聞くもの 嗅ぐもの
味わうもの 体で触れるもの
そういうものに依存して楽しむ生活から離れる
いわゆる依存生活から離れる意味なんです
オンリっていうのは依存しないという意味なんです
例えば 楽しむためにご飯に依存する
音楽に依存する 美しいものに依存すると
それはオンリじゃないんです
美しいものに依存するともう大変ですよ
服買うにも色やら絵柄やら色んなことを考えなくてはいけないし
デザインも考えな いけないし
メーカーのことも考えなくていけないし
家作るにも周りはどうですかとかね
背景はどうですかとか
そこまで考えなくてはいけないし
それであらゆるところに行って習って
花の立て方やらね そういうものを習わなくちゃいけないし
そこで今日はこういう花で飾り作りましょうと言ったら
いろいろ車に車飛ばして
そういう花を売っているところを探さなくちゃいけないし
自分がイメージした花が隣の花屋さんで売ってない場合はどうしますかね
また隣のその隣の花屋さんに行かなくちゃいけないでしょうに
で そういうことで 結構かなり大変です
それでその人は私は今日はもう四十キロも飛ばしちゃったよと
この花 この花を買うために
この形のこんな形の花が欲しかったんだよと
どうだい？すごい綺麗でしょ
確かにすごい綺麗ですよ
しかし その人は依存して楽しむんです
その花がなければ その人にはそちらで美学が現れてこないんです
目を楽しみが目の楽しみが現れてこないんですね
だからこのオンリっていうのは依存しない
依存しないことを楽しむ
すごい楽です 依存することを楽しむとすごい苦しいんです
それで依存する楽しみの場合は
例えばグルメ楽しむぞと思ったら食べ物に依存しているでしょ
結局はこの麻痺しちゃうんですよ
今日より明日もっと楽しい美味しいものを食べなくちゃいけないんだから
そこで食べ物を探さなくちゃいけないんですね
探して探していかなくちゃいけない
それにあらゆる苦しみが出てくる
一年前もって予約したりとかね
そういう人いますよ あの食べ物を食べたいんだと
それだったら一年で予約先予約しなくちゃいけないんだと
よくそんなことをやるんですね
お腹が空いたら何か食べれば
その場で何か探せばいいのに
で あの依存して楽しんで楽しむと
この物をたくさん付け加えなくちゃいけない
それを探さなくちゃいけない
それで探して得てもすぐ麻痺する
例えば珍しく花の立て方を覚えておいても
ものすごい綺麗な立て方を覚えても
毎日同じものになってくると面白くなくなっちゃうんですよ
刺激がなくなっちゃうんですよ
で そうすると変えなくちゃいけない
そこで依存依存しないことを楽しむ人にとっては
麻痺する問題はないんです
常に楽しみ楽しいんです
これが三番目ですね アッタナチャアサンサットアサンサッガカタンチャビックーナンカタッタ
アサンサットっていうのはいろんな関係を持ってることですね
いろいろ関係が 最近の人々はいろんな関係が楽しむんです
友人をたくさん作るは
知り合いをたくさん作るは
そこで私はあの人も知ってるんだ
この人も知ってるんだとかね
ある日本の方が私のところに随分久しぶりに来て
あまり面白い人でもないんですけど
喋るんで 私は何一つも聞かないで自分の世界に入ってるんです
で 一応体だけ貸してあげて
で 何言うかというと 分厚い何か
本みたいなものを持ってきて
これで名刺 名刺 名刺 いろんな世界中の人々のどこかの国際会議に行って
そちらにいた人々のみんなの名刺をもらってるんです
そうすると アメリカの何々さん
ドイツの何々さん インドの何々さん
イタリアの何々さんとかね
で この名刺の説明をするんですね
私はああそうですか ああそうですかと
口だけ体だけ貸してるんだからね
で あれは妄想の話で 実際にその人とあんたは友達ですかと
もう覚えてないと思いますけどもね
その人々は で 手紙のやりとりやったり
話し合ったり いろんなことをあったりするんだったらね
それは必要な関係かもしれませんしね
やっぱり人間っていうのはそうやってなんとか関係を持つことを楽しむんですよ
で 実際に関係あってもすごく煩わしいんですよ
例えば政治家と知り合ったとする
簡単に終わらないんです
それは 仲良くするためにこちらいろいろお金持って行ってあげなくちゃいけないわ
いろんな講演とかなんとかとか作ってあげなくちゃいけないわ
彼のあの美しいポスターをね
家の前で貼っておかなくちゃいけないのは
そういうふうな家見えますからね
東京でもね 誰か政治家のポスターを個人の家で貼っているとね
で ダサいというとね その人何者かとね
すぐそれで見えますからね
公のあの広告 あの貼る選挙になってくるとね
作るでしょ そちらに貼ってあったら誰のものでもないんだからね
いいのに自分の家に貼っちゃうと
で 人間にはそうやってなんとか関係を楽しむんだけど
それまた楽じゃないんです
自分の利益っていうのはどんどん失っていくんですよ
自分の仕事の時間 家族の面倒を見る時間
自分で勉強する時間 社会のために
もう人間のために何かやる時間っていうのは全部それになくなってしまうんです
どんな関係でも自分の自由を奪いますし
あのいろいろ苦労があるんですね
そこで出家した人にとっては
そういう弱い精神では仏道できません
誰かがいなかったら 喋る相手がいなかったら寂しいやという人の精神が弱いんですよ
その人の寂しさ その人の寂しさをなくすために
誰かがね 付き合ってあげると
そんな人いないでしょうに
あの人寂しいんだから
じゃあ行ってちょっと 2
3時間くらい喋ってあげましょうとかね
そうやって献身的に行く人間いるんですかね
そうすると自分の時間どうなるんですかね
だから寂しいと思う人はその分苦労しなくちゃいけない
人を呼ぶために 呼んだ人を泊まってもらうために
それは心が弱いんだからなんです
そんなにはキリがあるんですからね
いつでもできるわけじゃないんですよ
だからどうせ失敗で終わっちゃうんです
例えば一人の奥さんが
金持ちの奥さんが寂しくて
で 友達作ろうと思ってパーティーやると
これいつでもできるわけないでしょうね
金がたくさんあるんだったら
毎週一回はできるかもしれませんだけど
毎週パーティーやっちゃっても
参加する人々とはどんどん面白くなくなっちゃうでしょうね
だから今度の土曜日はちょっと申し訳ない
もうどこかに行きますよとか何とか言って
他の奥さんたちが逃げるでしょうし
たまたまパーティーだったらみんな奥さんたちがわーっと来てね
楽しく遊んでご飯食べて帰りますけど
例えば定期的に土曜日はこの家でパーティーがありますと行って
みんなに定期的に招待しておくと
みんな義理に義務になっちゃうんですね
土曜日はあのお家に行かなくちゃいけないんだと
でも自分の家でも土曜日は子供のいろんなことで出かけなくちゃいけないわ
旦那の仕事の関係でどこか行かなくちゃいけない
また別な誰かの誕生日パーティーに行かなくちゃいけないわとかね
そんなもの出てくるでしょうに
そうすると自分が寂しいんだからといって
定期的に毎週一回パーティーやったって上手くいかないんです
だから関係を持って楽しもうと思う人にとっては
結局得られるのは苦しみだけ
失敗だけで終わっちゃうんですよ
だからそういう弱い精神の生き方は仏教は認めません
みんな強い精神で生活しなくちゃいかん
だからこの在家の人々には期待できんだから
お釈迦様はそれはまあ出家の人々にはもう依存しない生活とこの関係を楽しまない生活と考えてくださいと
依存しないというと この身の回りの物質的なもので
で 今言ってるのは番目でしたっけ？番目はこの人間関係なんですね
だからこの仏教では この例えばスッタニパータとかね
あの犀の経典とかね ありますね
みんな読まれていらっしゃると思いますけどね
ああいうところでこの一人でいけと
一人で生活しなさいと
犀のようにと この例えはちょっとわからない
犀のようにっていってどういう意味かっていうとわからないんですけど
実際に犀っていうのはあの単独行動なんです
犀は二匹一緒には生活しない
動物園にいる犀でも やっぱり一匹一匹別々に入れてるんですよ
二匹一緒に入れちゃうと
もうやり合いちゃうんで
お互いに で ぶつかっちゃうんです
で それは自然から見て学んで例え使ってますけど
それでみんな一般 俗世間ではね
ああ つまらない教えだなと思っちゃうんですよ
そんな単純なことを言ってるわけじゃない
これ精神のことを言ってるんですよ
強い精神 一人でいられるというのは
次にアーラッダウィリヨ
アーラッダウィリヤっていうのは努力は絶えない
努力することは絶えないという
ここで何に努力するかというと
これ出家の話ですから
金儲かるためには大変努力するということではないんです
これがこのサティなんですね
サティの実践 気づきの実践
いわゆるヴィパッサナーですね
あとあとの時代の言葉借りて言うと
で で 常に気づいて生活する
それにサティを実践する
それには大変努力しないと
すぐ気づきがなくなっちゃうんです
で アーラッダウィリヤということで
このいくつかの注釈書の定義があるんですけど
経典の中でブッダの言葉の中から計算してみると
まあこれ気づきのサティの努力なんです
だからヴィパッサナー実践は一日何時間やればいいんですか？と私に聞くたびに
私はこれは時間やるんだよと言うでしょ
それは時間の作業なんです
絶えず気づく でないと精神的には成長しないし
悟れないし えーと 次 それから分かりやすいのアッタナー・シーラ・サンプンノ
えーと シーラ・サンプダ・カタンチャ・ビクーナン・カッタ
自分が道徳を守っていて
道徳的な戒律を守って
それから戒律についてよく喋る
他の人々にも これどちらにしたってもみんなと喋りなさいと
みんなといったっても比丘たち同業者たちと話し合いなさいよと
一緒に集めたら何か喋らなくちゃいけないんだから
お釈迦様はそういうテーマで喋りなさいと
これどんなテーマで喋っても頭が鋭くなる
例えば戒律について喋る
嘘は言っては 嘘をついてはいけないんだよとかね
それで嘘って何でつくんでしょうかとかね
人間嘘をついて何を得られるんでしょうかとかね
で そういうことを喋ると人生の勉強になるんですよ
今戒律について言ったんだから
例えば嘘をつくという
嘘をついてはいけないという戒律が
道徳があります そこでお坊さん二人
三人ぐらい集めて喋ります
やっぱり嘘をついてはいけないねとか
そうですねとかね それでなんで人間っていうのは嘘をつくんでしょうかね
それで考えなくちゃいけないでしょ
それは自分の利益のためでしょ
自分の利益のために嘘をつくっていうことは
相手を騙すことでしょうとかね
相手を騙して利益を得たら
これは正しい利益じゃないでしょう
不正的な利益でしょう
それも悪いでしょう 嘘をついたことも悪いし
自分の利益のために嘘をついたんだから
利益を得たところで人を騙したという新しい罪を犯しているし
そこで得た利益は不正的な利益でしょうし
それを使えば使うほど自分が悪いことをしているし
人を騙して利益を得て
その利益でいろんなものを買ったり食べたりする
その自体が悪行為になるでしょう
その得た利益で子供にご飯を食べさせたり
教育させたり 子供を養ったりするし
そうするとそれまた悪行為になるでしょう
子供がいる人は子供を養うのは当たり前のことなんですけど
これ当たり前のことをやって罪を犯してるんですね
罪を犯さずにできるのに
子育てでも仕事でも何一つも罪を犯さずできますよ
これで弱い者が嘘をついて簡単にやろうではないかと
簡単に儲かろうではないかと嘘をついたところで
それでずっと悪だけで流れてしまうんですね
だからそんな話っていうのはかなり智慧が必要でしょう
だから普通そういう話をしてほしいんですよ
仏教では だから仏教の人っていうのは本当に頭が鋭くなるはずなんです
だから もしある村が仏教徒になったら
その村が抜群に繁栄するはずなんです
ある国が仏教徒になると
とてつもない素晴らしい国になるはずなんです
一人一人すごい鋭い頭がありまして
それが経典の中でこのカンマーサダンマという町についてよく語っているんですよ
この四念処経というヴィパッサナー瞑想の経典を語った場所なんです
また いくつかの経典 その場所でお釈迦様はお話をしましたけど
このカンマーサダンマという大きな村ではない町というか
ニガマですからね ニガマっていうのは村も二十戸四十戸ぐらい集めた所のところなんですね
で そちらの人々というのはみんな常にこのサティについて喋るんだと
気づきについて喋るんだと
もう歩くときはどういう風に気づきましょうとかね
それで歩く時気づいたものやら
感覚に気づいたものやら
見たもの聞いたものについて気づいたものやら
ずっとそういうことを喋るんだと
だからすっごく鋭く頭がいいんだと
だから注釈書でカンマーサダンマという町の人々っていうのは
もう特別に智慧がある人々として書いているんです
理由はお釈迦様がおっしゃった通りにサティを実践するんだと
そこで何言いたがってるんでしょうかというと
ブッダの教えを実践してみれば
みるみるうちに智慧が開発されていって
立派な人間になるんだという話なんですね
そういうことだから 例えば戒律について語っても
頭がみるみるうちに良くなりますよ
で 殺生してはならないんですよと喋る場合でも
殺生って何なのかとかね
命を奪うことでしょう
命を奪うっていうことは
それ怒りでやるでしょう
自分のために他人の命を奪うとかね
これどう見たっても不公平なことでしょうとかね
そこで自分のために他人に害を与える人の命は危ないんじゃないですかと
誰も守ってくれないのではないかと
平気で他を殺す人は誰も守ってくれないでしょうに
守ってあげたらまた迷惑だから
平気で他を殺すんだから
だから他を殺す人はもう自分も死んだ方がいいという法律を作ってるんです
自分死んだ方が他人に対しては幸せやと
ということで考えてみるとすごい弟子が現れてきますよ
だから人間というのは
この王様について 政治について
戦争について語ってはいけないと
の喋ってはいけない話があるんです
王について 大臣たちについて
政治について 軍人に 軍隊について
踊りについて あらゆる乗り物について
花の飾り方についてとかね
服についてどんなデザインで今流行ってるんですかとかね
それは語ってはいけない
頭が悪くなるんだと その代わり
仏教はそういうすごい知識的なことを語る
と推薦するんです そこでシーラですね
戒律 次にサマーディ・サンパンノ
自分が心を統一するんです
しているんでしょうか
それから心を統一することについて比丘たちと語り合ってるんでしょうかと
いわゆる瞑想して あの
まあ私はこういうこういうふうに状態ですけど
そちらはどういうことでしょうかと
で そちらの人はあまりそこまで進んでないんだったら
どこら辺問題あるんでしょうかとかね
そうやって自分の精神統一状態について語り合う
次アッタナ・パンニャ・サンパンノ
自分が智慧のある人になる
また智慧について語る
これも理解してほしい
どうやっていきなり智慧の人間になれるんですかね
まあそうでもないんですけど
一応もう別なポイントを言いたいんですね
ブッダの教えは万人に通用するんですよ
神々 人間 あらゆる生命に実践できる
通用通じる教えなんです
一人にでもできないと言ったら
もう完全たるブッダの教えにならなくなっちゃうんです
やれば誰にでもできますよという態度は絶対変わらないんです
仏教では いわゆる失格者はいないんです
まあ失格者はまあ決めてはあることあるんですけど
それはコミュニケーション成り立たないね
例えば生まれつき一応これで生まれると
もうその人は過去の業でもうコミュニケーション成り立たない状態になってしまって
もう話しても話は通じない
人間が死んで犬になってしまったと
お手と言ったらわかるかもしれませんだけど
もうそれ以上わからないんですね
だからコミュニケーション成り立たない
そういう失格があるんですけど
人間であるならば 神々であるならば
誰にでも通じる話なんです
ということは 我々は一応五感ついてる人間でしょ
コミュニケーションはできるでしょ
だったらいきなり智慧の人間になれるはずなんです
そこで智慧って何なのかと
智慧ってば知識ではありません
知識っていうのは付け加えるものですよ
地理学勉強するとかね
パーリ語を勉強するとかね
何か付け加えるんですよ
概念 頭の中に そうすると器いっぱいになってももう何も入らないという状態にはなります
器小さければたくさん勉強できないんですよ
器大きければもう柔軟性あればたくさん勉強できるんだけどね
だから知識だったら万人にできるということではありません
ピアノは万人に弾けるわけじゃないんですよ
やっぱりその器持って生まれる人々がいるんですよ
その人々は弾けばいいんです
いろんな知識の世界っていうのは
もう能力ありなしっていうのは生まれつきほとんど付いちゃうし
あるいは長い間訓練すればつくっていうことはあります
だから智慧はそうじゃないんです
これ万人に付くものなんですよ
仏教で智慧っていうのは知識ではありません
すべて無常だと見ることですよ
簡単です 一切ことごとく無常であると
止まって変わらないものっていうのは何一つもないんだぞと
それぐらいは誰にでも考えられるでしょうに
こんな勉強できなくても
その思考で生きてみるんですよ
花見たらなんて綺麗ですかではなくて
この花はまあ一応三日で枯れるでしょうと
この花だったら二週間でしょうとかね
なんて綺麗でしょうっていう感じじゃないんです
何を見ても であの下にイチョウの木があって
この昨日はできなかったんですけどね
有吉君が登らせてあげたんですけど
あいつはもう全部葉っぱを取るんです
私は怒って まあ怒るなかでそんな取るなよ
かわいそうよと あんたに乗ってると登ってるでしょうに
この木に 大事にしなくちゃとかいろいろ言ったんで
全然聞いてくれない で
そのそれを見たらね 私はね
今はイチョウの葉っぱがね
緑色で頑張っているんですけど
まあそろそろね 全部落ちる
止まってないんです ずっと変化しつつ
そういう風に見るということは
こんなのは誰にでもできますよ
マリア君の年からもうそれぐらい教えてあげることはできます
無常ってそれが知恵ですよ
そういう人々は 俗世間の知識もとても簡単に身につくんです
なぜかというと 何でも無常だからストレスたまらないんです
この勉強は苦しい  なんで苦しいって言ったって一時間ぐらいのことだからと
習っちゃえば終わりでしょうと
そういう風な すごい小さく見るんですよ
知恵がある人は この世の中にある膨大な知識を小さく見るんです
知恵がない人にとっては
知識っていうのはあまりにも巨大に見えるんです
乗り越えられない 山のように見える
だから人は知識ではなくて知恵を育てる
知恵っていうのは どんなおじいさんにおばあさんにも
どんな子供にも 万人にできる
すべて無常だと見る ご飯自分の皿に付いたところで
ああ 美味しいですねとかね
そういう無知な感想ではなくて
瞬時にこれどうなるんでしょうかと
どんなものに変化するんでしょうかと
この美味しい香りのいい形の美しい
この食べ物は瞬時にどうなるんでしょうかと
そういう風にこの見方を変えてみることは知恵なんです
無常っていうのはわかりやすく実践しやすいし
無常だけじゃなくて空と無我というね
また 2つもありますけど
知恵の定義それ大したことものすごい難しいというわけでもないんです
そこで自分が智慧を持ってますか？同業者たちに智慧について語りますかと
例えば名古屋でビル爆破事件が起こって
はぁもったいないなとかそういう話じゃなくて
やっぱり二 三秒でどんなビルでも倒れるもんだなとかね
そういう風な見方で見るんです
そこでアッタナ ヴィムッティサンパンノ ヴィムッティサンパダカタン ビックーナンカタッタ
自分が解脱を得て 比丘たちにも解脱について語りますかと
次にアッタナ ヴィムッティニャーナダッサナサンパンノ
ヴィムッティニャーナダッサナっていうのは解脱を得たという確認なんです
解脱を得た人は解脱を得た立場から
その境地からもう一度現象世界を見るんですよ
この目が見えなくて 汚い服を着ているのに
なんて綺麗な服を私は着ているんでしょうかと威張っている世界をね
もう一度見ると 自分がどれほど解脱して物事から離れているんですかと
それを再確認に起こるんですね
自分が絶対戻ることはないんだと
このお釈迦様でももう私は全て終わった
やることも終わった やることは何もない
完全に修行を成し終えた
解脱をしました 煩悩は消えた
戻れませんよと徹底的に言うのはこのヴィムッティニャーナという解脱知なんですね
それは解脱した瞬間でわかるものじゃないんです
解脱したら次に自分にどうなったかということは
また再確認すると ああ
すごいことをやったもんだなとわかるんです
だから解脱を得てから
また次から次といろんな智慧が出てきます
それはそんな驚いたことはないんですけど
やっぱり説法するためには
お釈迦様にしたっても
どんどんお釈迦様の説法がまとめてまとめていくでしょうに
最初の説法は失敗しましたから
そこで自分の解脱の智慧で俗世間をまた見直してみて
あ こう言えば理解してくれると
それでいろんな例えを導入したり
おとぎ話を導入したり
人々に質問を出したり
人を脅したり けなしたり
いろんな方法でみんな悟りに導く
だからヴィムッティニャーナ
解脱の解脱智慧ですね
解脱智慧っていうのは
この方法弁として使ったものなんですね
次にオーワードコ ウィンニャーパコ サンダッサコ サマードパコ サムッテージャコ サンパハンサコ サッブラフマチャーリーナンティ
で そんなセット それで終わります
解脱を得て 解脱の解脱を得たという再確認を得たところで
修行もすべて終了するんですからね
それがオーワードコ みんなにアドバイスする
ウィンニャーパコ 説得させる
サンダッサコっていうのは
あらゆるデモンストレーションをするというか
いろんなモデルを持って教える
サマードパコっていうのはこのやらせる
サムッテージャコっていうのは応援する
やりなさいやりなさいよと
面白いよと サンパハンサカっていうのは
この応援することよりもさらに刺激的に応援することなんですね
なんて言いますかね  鼓舞する
奨励する  奨励  励ます  ただやりなさいやりなさいではなくて
やったらすごい面白いぞとかね
なんとか言ったら これは本人がものすごく面白くなっちゃって
やらずにはいられない状態にするという
やはり喜ばせるという意味になりますけど
そういう風に この道徳について
あなたは相手にアドバイスするか
教えてあげるか 納得させるか
それからいろんな例え話でデモンストレーションして教えるか
みんなに実践させるか
みんなを応援するか みんなを刺激させてさせる
させているか この修行についてと
項目いくつあったっけ
個ですか  個ですね その個で仏道全部なんです
そこでちょっとつなぎがちょっとわからないんですけど
次に百四十六ページで
プンノーナマバンテアヤスママンターニプットージャーティブーミヤンジャータブーマカーナンビックーナンサブラクマチャーレーナンエーワンサンバービトと
あのお坊さんたちがお釈迦様に報告するんですね
プンナという名前のお坊さん
フルネームはプンナマンターニプッタ
ファミリーネームはマンターニプッタ
マンターニの息子という
それは母親の名前ですね
プンナマンターニプッタというお坊さんがジャーティブーミヤンジャーティブーマカーナンビックーナン
このジャーティブーミという国境の比丘たちに
エーワンサンバーイと
こういう風に人気あるんだと
すごい有名な 有名ですよと
サンバーイタっていうのは有名ですよと
どのように有名かというと
アッタナーチャアッピッチョアッピッチェカタンチェバックーナンカタッタ
お釈迦様はどうですか？もう国境の比丘たちが自分でアッピッチェで小欲でいて
他人に小欲のことを教えているんでしょうかとか
十項目言ったところで
この坊さんたちが 釈尊
プンナという長老が これ有名ですよと
これについては 自分が小欲で
他人には散々小欲について語るんだと
自分が満足生活していて
他人にもずっとそれを語り続けているんだと
自分が依存しない生活をして
他人にも依存しない生活を語り続けているんだと
関係持たない生活を自分で持っていて
他人にも関係持たない生活を語り続けているんだと
で 戒律も精進努力を絶やす
自分が絶えない精進努力しながら
他人にも絶えない精進努力について語っているんだと
自分が戒律を守って 他人にも戒律について語っているんだと
自分がサマーディ 禅定
統一を得て 他人にもサマーディ
禅定 統一についてよく語り続けているんだと
自分が智慧を開発して
他人にも智慧について語るんだと
自分が解脱を得て 他人にも解脱について語っているんだと
自分が解脱知見を得て
他人にもそれについて語っているんだ
それだけじゃない みんな奨励しているんだ
みんな励ましているんだと
そこで会話が終わるんです
お釈迦様はどうですかと聞いたら
大丈夫だよ プンナ長老がお釈迦様おっしゃる通りですよと
すごい有名ですよと テーナコウパナサマエーナアヤスマサーリプットーバガヴァトーアビドゥーレーニシンノーホーティー
そこでお釈迦様のそばにサーリプッタ尊者も座っていたんです
その会話聞いていたんです
で この内容は この十項目は
いかにすごいかということは
もうサーリプッタ尊者が思い存分わかっているんだからね
大体サーリプッタ尊者というのは
ただ言葉を聞いただけで
ものすごく明確に理解する
で サーリプッタ尊者がびっくりしたんだ
お釈迦様見事に十項目にすべてコンパクトにまとめてみせましたから
出家の生き方 仏道そのもの
ブッダの教えは何なのかとコンパクトに見せたんです
だからこの日本にもあるこの一冊で全てがわかる本というのは
[笑い]３分に仏教の全てがわかる本とかいっぱいあります
五百円で [笑い]その四句は仏教でもありますね
[笑い]ブッダの教えは何なのかと言えば
全部この十項目でわかると
で それ聞いてサーリプッタ尊者がアタコアヤスマトサーリプッタッスエタダホーシ
サーリプッタ尊者こういうことを考えました
ラーバアヤスマトプンナサマンターニプッタッサ
スラーバアヤスマトプンナサマンターニプッタッサ
ヤッサヴィンニューサブラマチャーリーサットゥサンムカー
アヌマスアヌマッサアヌマッサワンナンバサンティ
タッタンジャサッダアッバヌモーダティ
アッ
デーワチャナーママヤンカダーチカラハチアヤスマタプンネーナマンターニプッテーナサッディンサマーガッチャイヤーマアッデーワナーマシーヤーコーチデーワカタサッラーポーティ
サーリプッタ尊者がびっくりしてこう思いますよ
プンナマンターニプッタ長老は本当に得しているんだと
スラッデラーバ 大得しているんだと
見事に得をしているんだと
なんでかというと ウィンニューサブラマチャーリー
この同業者たちが一緒に修行するお坊さんたちが
またウィンニュー かなり智慧のある
かなり知識人である エリートであるお坊さんたちが
こんなにお釈迦様の前でプンナ大長老のことを褒めるのではないかと
こんなに見事に それまたお釈迦様がその通りだ
その通りだと認めること
そう言われたってもどうでしょうかと
心配何一つもなく ということは
プンナ長老っていうのは並大抵の阿羅漢ではないんです
お坊さんたちの中ですごく有名で
それまた中途半端なお坊さんたちではなくて
もう修行を完成してお釈迦様に対等に話し合うできるエリート中のお坊さんたちが
プンナ長老はすごいんだよと言うんだから
プンナ長老の立場っていうのはものすごいすごいんですね
そこでまたお釈迦様はそれを認めるんだからということで
それでサーリプッタ尊者もそんな偉いお坊さんに一度会いたいと
会って話したいんだと
一度会うことをできればありがたいなと
会ってないんですね この二人が
会って話し合いできればいいなと
で それからこの経典の役柄は変わるんです
お釈迦様から弟子たちに
で ここから大変です 弟子たちの方に変わったら
もう結構中身は難しくなるんです
専門的になるんです アタコーバガバラージガヘヤタービランタンリハリッツーイエナサーワッティーテーナチャーリカンパッカーミー
お釈迦様は王舎城からサーワッティー城に旅に出ました
アヌプッデーナチャーリカンチャラマーノイエナサーワッティータダワサリー
順巡礼で歩いてサーワッティー町に入りました
タッタスダンバガワーサーワッティアンヴィーラティジェータワニアナータピンディカッサーラーミー
そこでお釈迦様が祇園精舎でしたっけ
あのアナータピンディカ孤児のお寺で住むことになりました
アッ
ソーシコーアヤスマプンノマンターニプットーバガワーティルサーワッティンアヌッパットーサーワッティアンヴィーラティジェータワニアナータピンディカッサーラーミーティ
そこでプンナ長老にこのニュースが流れたんです
お釈迦様が王舎城から舎衛城に移りましたと
アタコーアヤスマプンノマンターニプットーセーナーサナンサンサーメッターパッタチーバランアーダヤイエナサーワッティーテーナチャーリカンパッカーミー
プンナ長老もサーワッティーは自分が住んでいるところにはいくらか近い
王舎城はかなり遠い だからさっさと自分の荷物をまとめて旅に出たんです
だから荷物少ない方が楽ですよ
思ったらすぐ出かけるんだから
アヌプッデーナチャーリカンチャラマーノイエナサーワッティージェータワナンアナータピンディカッサーラーモイエナバガワーテーヌプサンカーミー
それで旅に出て どんどんどんどん舎衛城まで行って
お釈迦様いるところに行きました
行ってお釈迦様に会いました
ウパサンカミットワ・バガワンタン・アビワディットワ・エーカマンタン・ニッシーディ
もう語らぬ座りました
エー
カマンタン・ニッシンノーコー・アヤスマンタン・プンナンマンターニ・プッタン・バガワー・ダンミャー・カタヤ・サンダッセーシ・サマーダペーシ・サムッテージェーシ・サンパハンセーシ
それでお釈迦様はもう勝手に何か説法したんですね
プンナ長老に 別に互いに悟り開いてるでしょうし
プンナ長老というのは大阿羅漢でしょうし
別に何か質問とかなんとかってないんだから
まあただごく普通の説法しましたと
そちらでもあのリストが来るんですよ
ダンミャー・カタヤ・サンダッセーシ
説法をよく説法しましたと
教えたと サマーダペーシ
いわゆるこのもう認めてもらう
納得させてもらう サマーダペーシっていうのは
サムッテージェーシっていうのはまあ奨励する
サンパハンセーシっていうのはかなり刺激的にもう奨励するという
やっぱり人間というのはいくらかこの感動やら刺激があった方が覚えやすいんですよ
話を聞いただけで 理屈だけでは面白くないんですよ
話を聞いて なんかすごく感動して
刺激も受けた方がもうしっかりと頭にそれ残るんですね
だからそこはちょっとしたこの美的な
あの 話術的なところなんですけどね
みんなにできるわけでもないんですね
この話術もやっぱりお釈迦様のほうがまあ完璧ですからね
アタ
コー・アヤスマ・プンノ・マンターニ・プットー・バガワター・ダンミャー・カタヤ・サンダッシトー・サマーダピトー・サムッテージトー・サンパハンシトー・バガワ
トー・バーシタン・アビナンディットワ・アヌモーディットワ・ウッターヤサーナ・バガワンタン・アビワディットワ・パダッキナン・カットワ・イエナ・アンダワナン・テーナ・パッカミ・ディワー・ヴィハーラーヤ
プンナ大長老はお釈迦様のお話を聞いて大変喜んで理解して
お釈迦様を三回右回りを回って時計回りに回って
でお釈迦様に礼をして
あの 出て出かけたんです
そこら辺にある森の中にアンダワナという
昼そちらにいるそうと
アタコー・アンニャタロー・ビックー・イエナ・アヤスマ・サーリプットー・テーナ・ウパサンカミ
そうすると ある比丘がサーリプッタ尊者のところに行きました
ウパサンカミットワ・アヤスマタン・サーリプッタン・エータダ・ウォーチャ言ってサーリプッタ尊者に報告するんです
ヤッサ・コートワン・アウソー・サーリプッタ・プンナッサ・ナーマ・ビックーノー・マンターニ・プッタッサ・アビンナン・キットヤ・マーノー・アホーシ
ソー
・バガワター・ダンミャー・カタヤ・サンダッシトー・サマーダピトー・サン・サムッテージトー・サンパハンシトー・バガワトー・バーシタン・アビナンディットワ
・アヌモーディットワ・ウッターヤサーナ・バガワンタン・アビワディットワ・パダッキナン・カットワ・イエナ・アンダワナン・テーナ・パッカントー・ディワー・ヴィハーラーヤ・アティと
全部報告しました
どういう報告かというと
サーリプッタ尊者がプンナというお坊さんのことを随分褒めてたでしょ
会いたい会いたいとおっしゃってたでしょ
そのお坊さんがね 今お釈迦様に会って
説法も聞いて お釈迦様に
三回礼をして 今アンダラに行きましたよと
そのプンナ長老はあんたすごく会いたがっていたお坊さんが
アタコーアヤスマサーリプットタラマナルーポニシーダナンアーダーアヤスマンタンプンナンマンターニプッタンピッティトピッティトアヌバンディ
これはシーサーヌローキーなんですけど
そこでどうなったかというと
サーリプッタ尊者がタラマナルーポを慌てて急いで
ニシーダナンアーダーへ
座るもの 座具ですね それもさっさっと持って
アヤスマンタンプンナンマンターニプッタンピッティトピッティトアヌバンディ
後ろから追っかけていたんです
シーサーヌローキーも頭の方を見ながら遠く行くんですね
距離もありますから もうあまり後ろも見ないんだからね
阿羅漢たちは 後ろを周りあまり見ないで歩くんです
で サーリプッタ尊者ってえらいお坊さんサーリプッタ尊者なのに
なんかすごく可愛いところいっぱいあるんですよ
もうなんかもう失敗するわ
弟子たちにいろんなひどい目に遭わせるわ
全然気にしないという
なんか知識人特有な特色ありますよ
ある日サーリプッタ尊者の沙弥かな
若い弟子一人がサーリプッタ尊者住んでいる部屋に火をつけたんですよ
腹が立って で そういうことまで起こるんです
でもサーリプッタ尊者が何のことなく落ち着いてるんです
お釈迦様困るんです なんであんたそんな調子ですかと
もうもうちょっとしっかり叱りなさいよと言っても
あんまり厳しく叱るということはしない
ってあんたにも言ったでしょう
智慧のある人はね 怒ったり感情を出したりはしないんです
もうこれは智慧の第一人者なんですよ
たくさん弟子たちがいたんです
お釈迦様はいつでも誰か出家したらサーリプッタ尊者ところにも放り込むんです
教えてくれるんだから
しかしサーリプッタ尊者は誰一人に怒らないんです
なぜならば智慧の第一人者だから
教え方は知ってるんです
なんであんたこれわからないのかという話はないんです
だから特にこの子供が出家すると
ほとんどサーリプッタ尊者のところに
子供っていうのはどうしてもちょっと扱いにくいところもあるし
もう遊んじゃうし 難しい仏教の話なんかはね
もう聞かないだろうということもあるし
これが子供に見事に教える
何のことなく そこで子供サーリプッタ尊者のことはもうなんかもう自分の遊び相手にしたりもするし
わがままを言うし 言ってはいけないんですよ
あまりにも尊い方だから
あまり子供は遠慮しないんだからね
一回出来事あったでしょ
このサーリプッタ尊者がすごく甘いもの好きなんですね
お菓子好きなんですよ
で ある沙弥が托鉢に出ていて
で サーリプッタ尊者がその村に来たということを信者さんが聞いて
あ サーリプッタ尊者来たんだからいっぱいお菓子作りましょうと
お布施できるんだからといって
ものすごく珍しいお菓子なんですね
なんかこの蒸しパンみたいな
蒸し焼きみたいに作る柔らかい甘いお菓子ですよ
これたくさん作ってサーリプッタ尊者のところに持っていったんで
お布施で サーリプッタ尊者も好きだからね
で これ自分も召し上がって
他のお坊さんたちにも配ったんです
そこでサーリプッタ尊者がもういいところは
あの托鉢に出たあの子にも一部置いておきましょうと
で 一部置いておいたんです
置いたんだけど その子は托鉢に出た
出たばっかしでなかなか帰ってこない
あっちこっちもういろいろ見ながら托鉢に出たでしょう
おそらく そこで待ってるわ待ってるわ
来ない で 信者さんも待っている
で 信者さんたちが沙弥がもう帰ってくる時になってくると
もう昼過ぎてるでしょう
午前中はなんか帰ってくるようもないんですよと
だからこれはサーリプッタ尊者召し上がってくださいと
だからみんなに配ったんだから均等に配るでしょ
だからこれせっかく作ったのサーリプッタ尊者のために作ったんだからね
もう人分 人分作っても
サーリプッタ尊者のために作ったもんだから
信者さんにとってはサーリプッタ尊者が一個だけでも余分に召し上がってほしいんですね
それで信者さん いや これはやっぱりサーリプッタ尊者召し上がった方がいいんじゃないんでしょうかと言ったら
そうだねって言って それ召し上がっちゃったんです
召し上がって終わるとやっぱりあの沙弥が来るんですよ
で サーリプッタ尊者「あー申し訳ない
子供のもの食べちゃって」とかねって気持ちもあるし
それは子供に言うんですよ 「
まあ君のお菓子の分も置いといたんだけど
君が遅いんだから私は食べましたよ」と言ったら 「
そうね 美味しいものだったらみんな好きだから」と
サーリプッタ尊者に文句言ったんですよ
美味しいものになってくるとね
みんなそんな調子だから
理性のこと忘れるんだと
まあ向こうは子供だからね
子供は機嫌が悪いでしょうね
それすごく心に引っかかったんですよ
それっきりお菓子食べなかったんです
それが良くないんだと
それっきりお菓子は見せなくなった
だからそういうすごくこの面白いエピソードいっぱいサーリプッタ尊者の周りにあるんですよ
だからサーリプッタ尊者だからね
もうプンナ長老を呼べばいいでしょうしね
他の比丘たちにあんた行って呼びなさい
私のところに来るようにと
サーリプッタ尊者の方が上だから
お釈迦様の次だから 出家の年も上だと思いますしね
そんなことはしない 自分が仏教で第一人者であるということは全然もう気づいてないぐらいです
だから長老も お釈迦様
サーリプッタ尊者あえて選んだんですよ
で だからあのお坊さんのプンナ長老の頭の方を見ながら
どこに行くんでしょうかというのは
後ろから早く早くもう焦って慌てて行ったんです
アタクーアヤスマプンノマンターニプットーアンダワナンアッジョーガーヒットワアンタアンニャタラスミドッカモーレーディワーヴィハーランニセーディ
で プンナ長老が森の中に入って
適当な木のそばで木の下で座りました
アーヤスマアピコーサーリプットーアンダワナンアッジョーガヒットワアンニャタラスミドッカモーレーディワーヴィハーランニセーディ
サーリプッタ尊者もそこら辺の木の下でまた座りました
それでその瞑想に禅定に入るんですよ
瞑想に入る だから喋りません
アタクーアヤスマサーリプットーサーヤンナサミアンパティサッラーナウッティトージェーナーヤスマプンノマンターニプットーテーノパサンカミ
そこでずっと禅定に入っていて
午後になって まあ夕方ぐらいかな
そこ時間になったら禅定から明けて瞑想から明けてマンターニプッタ長老のところに自分で行くんです
ウパサンカミットーアヤスマタプンネーナマンターニプッテーナサッビンサンモーディ
まあ話し合う サンモーディニャンカタンサーラーニニャンヴィーティサーレットワエーカマンタンニセーディ
それで話し合って座りました
そこから あ まだ三時半ですかね
どこまでやるんですかね
ここからは で また別な項目に入ります
そこでやっとプンナ長老とサーリプッタ長老が会話になります
[咳]サーリプッタ長老
こういう質問するんです bhagavati
no āvuso brahmacariyaṃ vussati ti
あの āvusoっていうのは友達という
友達ということで あんたはbhagavati
お釈迦様の教えにおいてbrahmacariyaṃ
修行しているんですかと
いわゆる仏教の修行者でしょうかと
友人は仏教の修行者でしょうかと訊ねるんです
それは余計やと思いますけどね
その質問は [笑い]まあでも初めて会った人だからね
なんか知ったかぶりをしてはいけないでしょうね
ですから evaṃ āvuso
その通りですと kinu
kho āvuso sīlavisuddhaṃ bhagavati brahmacariyaṃ vussati
で sīlavisuddhaṃ
これがこのvisuddhiっていうのは清らかになったという
きれいになったという意味なんですね
で 解放された きれいになった
汚れが落としたという
それでsīlaっていうのは戒律ですね
で 戒律はなぜ守るかというと
人間っていうのは本来悪いんだからなんですね
人間っていうの本来の状態っていうのは嘘ついたいし
もう欲しいものは与えてあっても与えてなくても
他人のものでも自分でもらいたいしね
怒りたいし 嫌なものは殺したいし
そういうのはごく普通の人間の感情なんですよ
だからこのsīlaでもって
そういう心の非道徳的な感情を全部洗いさらい
洗い 洗い出して 心はきれいにする
まあ嘘はついたくはない
殺生したくない状態ね
心育て上げる ですから心の汚れがついているんだから
心がすごく悪いことをしたくなるんです
そこで最初に道徳を守って心はきれいにするということはsīlavisuddhiなんです
そのためにあんたは修行しているんですかと
いわゆる戒律を完璧に守って
それなりにすごい清らかな心育てようではないかという目的でしょうかと
それで答えはno hidā āvuso
いえ 違いますと kiṃ
pana āvuso cittavisuddhaṃ bhagavati brahmacariyaṃ vussati
ではcittavisuddhiのために修行しているんですかと cittavisuddhi
っていうのは あの 心にはこの嘘ついたいとかそういうことがなくても
心は弱いんですよ いわゆる戒律を守ってあっても心は弱い
混乱しちゃう 落ち着きがない
精神的に力がない cittavisuddhi
っていうのは 心のこの弱みをなくして
しっかりした硬い心を作る
安定した心を作ることなんです
普通は禅定という状態なんですね
すごい精神的な統一した力を育てて
集中力を徹底的に育てるという
だからそれは戒律を守るよりも一段階上なんです
戒律を守るということは
まあごく普通の心でできます
で 完璧に戒律を守っていたっても
心は普通のレベルなんです
心は綺麗ですけど 普通のレベルです
それでcittavisuddhiってのはかなり心を強化してしっかりした心を作る
それはcittavisuddhiという
そのためにもいくらか汚れを落とさないと
いわゆる不安定 混乱 落ち着きない状態
浮つき状態 そういう心の状態も全部捨てないと心は硬くならないんですね
硬く安定した心にならない
それを目指して修行しているんですかと cittavisuddhi
うーん それでno hidā āvuso
そんな目的はないんだよと
次にkinu kho āvuso diṭṭivisuddhaṃ bhagavati brahmacariyaṃ vussati
ではあなたはdiṭṭivisuddhiのために修行しているんですかと diṭṭivisuddhi diṭṭi
っていうのはいろんな意見ですね
いろんな考え方 心っていうのは強くても
あらゆる概念が心の中に溜まってるんですね
いろんな意見 いろんな概念
いろんな考え方 それはいろいろ考え方あると
またこれはあまりいいということじゃない
だから一切の考え方 まあ世界は大きいか小さいか
私はなんで生まれたんですかとかね
来世はあるのかないのかとか
昔の考え方はそういうものでしょうし
現代人で言えばもう神様を信じるぐらいですからね
意見で言えばね そうやってあらゆる邪見
意見 見解から見解を心から追っ払って心をきれいにする
何も見解持たない人間になる
そのために修行するんですかと
言ったらこのボンナ長老は違うと言うんだからね
そんな目的はないんだよと
キンパナアウソカンカービタラナビスッダッタムバゴティブラフマチャリヤムウッサティ
で見解がなくって次のステージっていうのはカンカービタラナ
というカンカーっていうのは疑い
何なのか 何なのかというね
どうなってるんでしょうかという疑い
それもなくなってしっかり知る
こうだからこうなっている
というこの智慧のレベルなんですね
物事をちゃんと知っている
何も見解もない それでこの物事を理解するためにも
さらに心を育てるんですよ
すごく心を育てると いかなるものでもなぜ現れて
なぜ消えていくのかと
というすべて知っている
すべて知っている人にとっては何の疑いもないんです
世の中はどうなっているんでしょうか
私は生まれているんでしょうかとかね
私は私に来世があるんでしょうかとか
神がいるんでしょうかとかね
人間に魂があるのでしょうかとかね
そういう疑いはもう消えてしまう
こういう風に世の中あるものであると
はっきりと理解する智慧を開発する状態はカンカービタラナなんですね
疑いを乗り越えるという意味なんです
そのために修行するんですか？いわゆるあらゆるものを知るためにあんた修行してるんですか？と言えば
いえ 違いますよと そういう目的もないんですね
次にキンヌコアウソマッガマッガニャーナダッサナヴィスッディ
マッガマッガン  マッガアマッガ
マッガマッガマッガニャーナダッサナ
マッガマッガニャーナダッサナヴィスッダッタ
マッガっていうのは正しい道
アマッガっていうのは間違っている道
人間にとって 修行する人にとって
どんな道が正しい どんな道が間違っているかはっきり理解するために
道を発見するために あんた修行してるんですか？と
聞けば 違うんですよと
ノーヒタンアウソ キンパナアウソパティパダーニャーナダッサナヴィスッダッタムバゴティブラフマチャリヤムウッサティティ
ではパティパダーニャーナということは
この道と道 道と非道ですね
道と道でない その区別をして
それで道を発見した人は道を完成する
正しい修行の道 パティパダというのは正しい修行の道
正しい修行の道を歩んで完成して智慧を得て心育てる
心のまた弱みをなくなってしまう
そのために いわゆる 新しい道を歩むために
歩んで完成するためにあんた修行しているんですかと言ったら
答え違いますと なんかややこしいんですね
キンヌコアウソニャーナダッサナビスッダッタンバゴティブラフマチャリャムウッサーティ
これ七番目ですけど ではあなたはニャーナダッサナビスッディ
それで知恵を開発して
それで心は完璧にきれいにする
知恵の開発 そのために修行しているんですか？と言ったら
え 違いますと と言うんです
そこでこの言葉 ビスッディという言葉はキーワードなんですよ
で ビスッディっていうのはまあクリーンになったというね
クリーンになったということで
クリーンになるためには何か汚れを捨てなくちゃいけない
だから心はクリーン状態に
清らかな状態に七段階でなっていくんです
だから汚れは七段階で落として落としていくんです
ある汚れは最初に落とす
えーと シーラビスッディで落とす
ある汚れはチッタビスッディで落とす
ある汚れは えーと カンカービタ
ディッティビスッディで落とす
次の残ってる汚れはカンカービタラビスッディで落とす
次に残ってる汚れはマッガマッガニャーナダッサニで落とす
次にパティパダーニャーナダッサニで落として
七番目でニャーナダッサニで全部汚れを落としちゃうんです
それ以上落とす汚れがないんです
知恵の 知恵が完成したらもう全て汚れが落ちているんです
あんたその全ての汚れ
七番目のステージ それを目指して頑張っている
違いますと 言うとわけがわからなくなりますね
なんで修行するんですか？と
ことになります それで経典続きます
それでサーリプッタ尊者がキンヌコアウソシーラビスッダッタンバゴティブラフマチャリャムウッサーティイティイティプットーサマーノノーヒダンアウソトワデーシ
あんたシーラビスッディのために修行するかと聞いたら違うというわ
チッタビスッディのための修行するかというと違うというわ
そこでディッティビスッディのためでもないし
ニャーナダッサナビスッディのためでもないとあんた言うんだよと
一体絶対何のために修行するんですかと次に聞くんです
キマッタンチャリヒアウソバゴティブラフマチャリャムウッサーティイティ
一体全体あんたは何で修行するんですかね
それで答え アヌパーダパリニッバーナッタンコアウソバゴティブラフマチャリャムウッサーティイティ
これがこの経典の  言葉ですよ
内容ですよ アヌパーダパリニッバーナッタンアウソバゴティブラフマチャリャムウッサーティ
まあ大体それで経典は終わります
でもこの七段階の説明っていうのはもう仏浄土論でもう四十
ものすごい膨大な量なんです
アヌパーダっていうのは何ものにも取れわれなく
取れわるる 一切にも執着することなく
パリニッバーナ 涅槃を得る
涅槃というのは消えるって意味だからね
何にも執着することないという涅槃を目指して私は修行しているんだと
そこでサーリプッタ尊者がこのアヌパーダパリニッバーナって何なのかと聞くんですよ
何にも執着することなく平安を得るというのはどういう意味ですか？と
キンヌコアウソシーラビスッディアヌパーダパリニッバーナ
この戒律で心完成することがアヌパーダパリニッバーナですか？と言えばノーヒダンアウソ
心を清らかにすることはアヌパーダパリニッバーナですかと言われて
それも違いますと では邪見から心を清らかにすることは涅槃ですかと
違いますと では疑から心を清らかにすることは涅槃ですかと
それも違いますね それで道と道でないものを区別判断する能力が涅槃ですかと
それもない では道を完成することが涅槃ですかと
それでもない では解脱を得るじゃなくて何でしたっけ
マッガマッガ ニャーナ
パティパダーニャーナダッサナ
ニャーナダッサナビスッディですね
知恵を完成することは解脱ですかと
それでもないんだと それは七つも解脱ではありませんと
と言うんです では キンヌコアウソ
うん キンパナアウソアンニャットライメーヒダンメーヒアヌパーダパリニッバーナアンティ
では聞きますけど この
この七つ以外のものですかと
アヌパーダパニッバーナというのは
ノーヒダが 違いますと
この七つの段階以外別なものですかと言えば
それでもないんだと そこでまたサーリプッタ尊者
あんたシーラヴィスッディも平安ではないというは
チッタヴィスッディも平安ではないというは
ディッティヴィスッディも平安ではないというは
カンカーヴィタラナヴィスッディも平安ではないというは
それからマッガマッガニャーナダッサナヴィスッディも平安でないというは
パティパダニャーナダッサナヴィスッディも平安でないというは
それからニャーナダッサナヴィスッディも平安でないと言うし
それと別なものは平安解脱だともそれでもないと言うんだから
ヤターカタンパナアウソイマッサバーリサアットダッタと
これどう理解すればよろしいでしょうかと
こういうふうにまとめてください
七段階の心の成長がある
で これ一つもこのお坊さんが目的にしていない
このお坊さんが目的にしているのは平安
心の完全たる平安 ではこの七つの一つ一つも心の平安で
一つもそうではないんだと
では心の平安というのはこの七つ以外別なものですかと言えば
いいえ 別そではないんだよと
それこれから別なものでもなきゃ
ではどう理解すればいいんでしょうかと
それで簡単に答えていくんですよ
シーラヴィスッディンチェアウソバガワアヌパーダパニッバーナパンニャーペッサ
サウパーダーナゲーワサマーナアヌパーダパニッバーナパンニャーペッサ
で相手に言うんですね
友よと 友達ですからね
まあ友人 このシーラヴィスッディ
戒律を完成することは無執着の平安だとお釈迦様おっしゃるならば
お釈迦様は執着することを無執着の平安だと言っていることになるんだよと
いわゆる心に頼って戒律を守らなくちゃいけないんですよ
心を土台にして だから戒律を守るために自分の心は判断能力する主体でしょ
自分の心を主体にして嘘言ってはいけない
心が嘘をつきたがるんですよ
そこでそれを主体にして心が
心が嘘をつきたがる だから私は嘘をつかない
心は殺生したがる だけどどれで私は殺生しないと戒律を完成するんです
そうすると心がなければ
自分というものが主体としてなければ
土台としてなければ 戒律っていうのは守れません
ということは 戒律を完成しても
戒律を完成するために支えになる心があるんです
だから自分の心で修行しているんだから
心は 道具でというか 心で修行することになるんですね
そうすると心に依存しているんですよ
だからアヌパーダにならないんです
もしお釈迦様が戒律を完成することは無執着の平安だと言ったならば
違うんだと これ執着ですよと
戒律を守っても執着があるんだと
心に執着した上で戒律を守れますから
チッタビスッディンチュ
次にチッタビスッディ
では心強化すること 統一すること
涅槃やと平安やと言ったら
これはアヌパーダにならない
無執着の平安になりません
なぜならば目的あるんだから
心 これを集中させなくちゃいけない
この心をサマーディ状態に育て上げなくちゃいけないんだから
何か残ってるんですよ
心というものが それに執着しているんですよ
だからそれがブッダを解く
ブッダが解く涅槃ではないんだと
で 他の七つにも同じ 他の五つも同じことなんですね
そこで疑をなく邪見をなくなる状態
で 心から邪見なくなるんだから
心土台でしょ こちら邪見がある
捨てましょう 捨てましょうというと心が大事な方になっちゃうんですよ
だから心に執着しているんです
だって心に疑がある 物事をはっきり判断しない
でははっきり判断できるように心を磨いておこうではないかと言っちゃうと
その心が大事な存在になっちゃうんですね
だから無執着でなくなっちゃう
そこで順番で疑をなくなってから
道と道非道の智慧が現れて
道非道の智慧も心に現れるでしょうし
次に道を完成する智慧も心に現れるし
道を完成する心も それでヴィモッティ
解脱も心に現れるし だから心に解脱を体験させてやるぞと思ったら
心が大事な存在になっちゃうんですよ
この無知な心に解脱体験してやろうではないかと思っちゃうと
心が解脱はするんだけど
心が解脱してるんですよ
そうすると心が大事な存在になっちゃうんですね
それで心に依存しているんです
無執着ではないんです
だからそこら辺難しいんですよ
理解が だからお釈迦様は解脱智慧を無執着の涅槃であるとおっしゃったならば
これは無執着の涅槃ではありません
解脱智慧は心に現れるものだから
心に執着しているんです
心に依存しているんです
だからそんなことを教えてないんだと
そこでこの七つ以外ですよと
無執着の涅槃は といえばどんなバカも涅槃を得られるんだよと
だったら だって一般人がプトゥッジャナ
俗人には戒律もないわ
サマーディもないわ 何一つもないでしょ
七つ以外 七つない人に悟り開けるんならば
一般人が悟れるんだよと
というと矛盾なんですよ
いわゆる悟ったのに一般人ということになるんです
いわゆる悟ったのに悟ってない人になっちゃうんですね
すごい矛盾が生じるんです
だからこの七つの清らかな段階以外
それと関係なく無執着涅槃あるわけじゃないんです
そんなの関係ないんだぞと言ったら
誰にも関係ないんだから
誰も戒律完成しようとしようとしていないわ
誰もサマーディ作ろうとしていないわ
だから七つから離れているものでもないんだよと
っていうのはわからないんですよ
これでも それで譬え話持ってくるんです
テーネヤウソウパマンテーカリッサミ
では君に譬え話をしますよと
ウパマーヤピイデーカッチェウィンニュープリサバーシタッサッタンジャーナアンティ
頭の良い人はこの譬え話ででも理解しますよと
それでセイヤターピアウソウランニョパセーナディッサコーサラッササーワッティアンパティワサンタッサ
サーケーテキンチデーワアッチャーイカンカラニアンウッパッジェイヤ
例えば君 このコーサラ王様に
コーサラ国王はサヘジョに住んでいるんです
このサーワッティーに住んでいるコーサラ王様にサーケータという町
これかなり遠いんです
そちらにキンチデーワアッチャーイカン
どうしてもやらなくてはいけない
いわゆる必然的なカラニアン
出来事がウッパッジェイヤ
現れる コーサラ王様が何かやらなくちゃいけない
サーケータに行って これはどうしてもやらなくちゃいけないことが現れると
あるあるとしましょう
タッサ アニャタラーチャ サーヴァッティン アンタラーチャ サーケータン サッタ ラタ ヴィニーターニ ウパッタ ペヨン
そこで王様がサーヴァッティからサーケータまで行かなくてはならない
王様が行くんだから結構大胆な工事になりますね
大胆な行事になるんですね
それで準備する人々はどうしますかというと
このサーヴァッティからサーケータまで七つの車を用意しておくんです
車とその行列をね こちらで人々にメッセージを送れば
じゃあそこで王様に乗る車やら王様のグループ乗る車やら
全部そちらで用意しておいて
それである距離でその車から降りて
次の車セットに乗る 乗ってまた一部を距離を行く
そういう順番で いわゆる王様が乗り換えて乗り換えて乗り換えていけばいいんです
一台一台の車がもうサーヴァッティからサーケータまでは行けません
そんな力があるわけじゃないんです
乗り換えないと そういうふうに用意するとしましょう
アタコ アウソ ラージャ パサニディ コーサロ
サーヴァッティヤ ニッカ ミットヴァ アンテー プラドゥワーラ パタマン ラタ ヴィニータン アヴィルーヘッヤ
パタメーナ ラタ ヴィニーテーナ ドゥティヤン ラタ ヴィニータン パープネッヤ
それでコーサラ王様が宮殿を出て
そちらに車を用意してるんです
ラタ ヴィニータっていうのは
このヴィニータっていうのは調教された
訓練されたって意味ないわゆるすごい立派な車ということでね
王様に乗るにふさわしい安全な車ということで
それで王様が宮殿から降りて
玄関にある車に乗ります
乗って行列と一緒にすごいスピードを出して行くんです
行ってからこの車の能力があるところで終わりますからね
まあ一応どんな車にしたってもね
まあここまでということもあるし
で 大体そういう偉い人がいる場合
行く場合は燃料を入れたりはしないんです
途中で 今も 総理大臣やら天皇陛下がどこかに行く場合は
車で行く場合は 途中でじゃあガソリン切れたんだからガソリン入れましょうとか
そこら辺のガソリンスタンドに行ったりって
それはありえないんです
だから車の距離は決まってるんです
飛行機の場合はやっぱり飛行機の距離決まってるんだから
そこで止まってそこで燃料を入れ替えたりはします
そこで王様が一番目の車に乗ってずーっと行って
次に二番目の車に乗り換える
乗り換えて二番目の車セットでずーっと行って
三番目に乗り換える そこで三番目から四番目に乗り換えて
そうやって乗り換えて乗り換えて
六番目の車に乗り換えて
ずーっと行ってサーキットで降りる
だから王様には途中で止まることも何もなくずーっと行けるんですよ
しかし 王様をサーキットまで持ち運ぶということは大変な仕事で
一日でできるわけじゃないんです
こんな調子だったら一日でもできるんです
車には問題はないんだから
そこで王様は何しますかというと
ひとつつ車捨てるんですよ
宮殿に乗って宮殿で乗った車はある距離に行ったらもう使えないんです
もう用がないんです それで次の車に用があるんです
それに乗るんです それでずっと行ったらもう用が終わったんです
次の車待ってるんだから
そちらに用がないんだから
次の車に乗り移る 我々も乗り換える時同じことでしょう
ある電車に乗って乗り換える駅に行ったら
その電車を降りる もうその電車は用がないんです
次の電車に乗る そちらに用がある
そこで次の乗り換え駅に行くまで行ったら
そこはもう様子見で次の電車に乗り換えるという風に乗り換えていくでしょうし
そんなことですね そこで番目の車でサーケータの自分の宮殿に入る
そこでタメナンアンテープロドワラガタンサマナンミッターマッチャーニャーティサーリプッタ
そこで王様が堂々と宮殿に入るでしょう
入ると王様の友達たちやら親戚たちやらそちらにいるでしょうし
そこをその人々はエヴァンプッチェイヨン
こういうふうに聞くでしょう
イミナートンマハーラジャラタヴィニーテーナサーワーッティアサーケータンアヌッパットアンテープロドワランティ
こういうふうに質問する
王様 あんたこの車でサーワッティからサーケータまで来たんですかね
と聞いたら 王様どう答えればいいんですかと
カタンビャーカルマーノヌクアウソーラージャパセンディコーサロサンマービャーカルマーノビャーカレイヤー
そこで王様はどのように返事すれば正しいでしょうかと
だから親戚が聞くのは
君この車で来たんですかと
サーワッティからサーケータまでと
そこでサーリプッタ尊者が王様は出すべき答えを言うんです
エヴァンビャーカルマーノクアウソーラージャパセンディコーサロサンマービャーカルマーノビャーカレイヤー
このように答えればよろしいと
イダメーサーワッティアンパティワサンタッササーケーテキンチデーワアッチャーヤンカルニャンウッパージタッサメーアンタラージャサーワッティンアンタラージサー
ケータンサッタラタヴィータニウッパッタペーソント
アタコワハンサーワッティヤニッカミットワアンタプラドワラパタマンラタヴィニータンアヴィルーヒンパタミンラタヴィニーテーナドゥティヤンラタヴィーヒタンパープニン
思うんですね そこで王様が正しい答えならば
こういう風に答えなくちゃいけない
私はサーケータに行きたかったんだから
私は車台を用意してもらったと
家来たちに それで台の車で宮殿で乗って一部を行って
そこから降りて その車を離して外して置いといて
台目に乗りましたと 台目に乗ってずーっと行って
そこから降りて台目に乗りましたと
それそういう調子に台目に乗って
もう台目を捨てる 台目に乗って
台目を捨てる 台目に乗って
台目捨てる 台目に乗っていって
それも捨てて それからも降りて
もう関係ない もうよすんだと
宮殿に入ったと エヴァンビャーカルマーノクアウソーラージャパセンディコーサロサンマービャーカルマーノビャーカレイヤー
だから彼がそういうふうに答えなくてはいけないんだよと
そこでエヴァメーワクアウソーシーラヴィスッディヤーワデーワチッッタヴィスッダッタ
そのようにもう君 このシーラヴィスッディ
戒律を完成するということは
もう心をきれいにするまでですよと
次に戒律を完成したら
すぐ心にチャレンジしなくちゃいけないんだよと
心をきれいにしたらディッティヴィスッディ
邪見から心をきれいにしなくちゃいけないんだと
だから邪見から心をきれいにする前に集中力を育てなくちゃいけないんです
その資格がついたら 次の仕事をする
邪見から心を清らかにする
そこは完成したら次の仕事を待っている
いわゆる疑から心を清らかにするという
そこ終わったら次にマッガーマッガ
道と道でない その区別を判断することを完成しなくちゃいけない
それ終わったら道を歩むという仕事があって
それ終わったら智慧を得脱を智慧を完成するという仕事
番目にあるんだと この智慧を完成するニャーナダッサナヴィスッディ
智慧を完成するということは
ヤーワデーワアヌパーダパリニッバーナッタ
ただ無執着の涅槃を得るためであると
智慧を完成して したところで心も捨てて
無執着の涅槃を体験する
だからギリギリまで心使うんですよ
使って最後の瞬間で心も捨てる
だから王様がギリギリまで車に乗ってます
いわゆる しかし宮殿に入る時は車をよそ見
だから涅槃に入る場合は知恵も要すみなんです
知恵もいりませんという話なんです
知恵が必要と思ったら
知恵は一つ執着なんです
涅槃にはには何も要りません
これで見事に仏道をプンナ長老が涅槃の状況
まあ答えてくれたんです
だからこのたとえ話を理解して
このものに執着しないっていうこと
このヴィパッサナー瞑想するとよく現れる現象で
ほんのちょっとうまくいったらこれに粘りついちゃって
先へ先へと行かないんですね
だからもうほとんど成功しないんですね
ほんのちょっとうまくいっちゃうと
うまくいったんだぞと言って
また元に戻るんです いくらうまくいっても
それはそこまでやと また次に進むんだと
また次に進むんだと 進めば進むほど何か新しく旅始めた
例えば飛行機に乗り換えるとえらい面倒くさいでしょ
乗り換えるたびにあの説明を聞かなくちゃいけないわ
もうシートベルトを締めなくちゃいけないわ
もううるさいんですけどね
うんざりだと一回聞いたらそれで十分ではないかと
もう非常口を確認してくださいとかね
酸素マスクはそういう風に下りるんだよとかね
そこでもう我慢して もう二
三時間乗って そこからまた空港で降りて
もう次の飛行機に乗ると
また同じプロセスでまたチェックをして
荷物をチェックをして
ボーディングパスを入れて
次の飛行機に乗るでしょう
それでそちら連中はもう初めて生まれて初めて飛行機に乗った態度をとるでしょうね
それでまたもうシートベルトしっかりしなさいとかね
あれやこれやと言われて
また説明も聞いて で また空飛ぶでしょうに
そこからまたもう苦労して降りたところで
また次の 3台目の飛行機に乗り換えるならば
また同じプロセスなんですね
また手荷物を検査させたりとかね
また輪っかからもうくぐらなくちゃあかんわ
またあの初期の説明しなくちゃあかんわとかね
だから一回乗ったんだからといってね
やっぱり旅はまだ終わってないんだからね
そこは気をつけてほしい
ヴィパッサナー瞑想ではね
なんかいつでも自分が進めないんではね
また初めからやるんですかと
初めからやってるわけじゃないんですよ
一回一回終わったら また次の乗り物に乗らなくちゃいけないんですよ
それでまたもう初心者の気持ちでまた始めなくちゃいけないんです
その順番はなかなか皆様方の報告ないと教えることはできないんです
一人でやっても あ これでいいやと思っちゃうんです
だからどうしても報告は必要なんです
報告を聞くと どこまで進んでいるか
まだ同じ車でよろしいかということわかるんです
もうそろそろ車乗り換えな
ということになってくると
こちらは乗り換えさせてあげます
こちらは乗り換えですよと
そこで乗り換え間違ったらとんでもないところに行っちゃうんです
結構乗り換え間違う人もいます
で ちゃんと基本忘れないならば
乗り換えは大体は間違わない
基本はどんな時でも同じなんです
ヴィパッサナーの場合は
そこでサーリプッタ尊者が「エーワンゴッテーアヤスマ
プンノーマンターニプットアヤスマント」いや違う 「
エーワンゴッテーアヤスマサーリプッタアヤスマントプンナンマンターニプッタンエータジオーチャイ」
こういう風に説明したら
サーリプッタ尊者がこんなことを言う 「
コーナーモーアヤスマ
カタンチャパナアヤスマントサッブラフマチャーリージャーニイティジャーナティティ」
あの 「君はどんな名前ですか？同業者たち
一緒に修行する人々は
あなたのことをどのように呼ばれているんでしょうか」と名前を聞くんです
この付き合いは面白いでしょう
名前を聞くのは最後なんです
いきなりもう重大な話になって
まあこれ日本やら西洋だったらね
ちょっと理解しにくいかもしれませんけど
私たちにとっては平気なんです
いきなり そういきなり話始まるんです
いろんな話 もう散々 まあ話し合いやらディスカッションやらもう討論やら何でもやって
最後に「あんたどこですかね
名前何ですか」と後で聞くんです
それはごく普通 別に紹介がなくても
自己紹介がなくても すぐ話に入るという
のはまあちょっとインド的ですね
まあ我々はインドもスリランカでも
まあそこら辺仏教文化があるところっていうのはね
ああいう態度 もう人間っていうのはみんな同じ友達じゃないかという態度をとるんですよ
例えばインドネシアとかイスラムの国だから全く異質ですけど
やっぱりバリ島とかね
ヒンドゥ教でしょ 私は日本人の友達と一緒にバリ島に行ったんです
で 友達が先に行ったので
私は後から行ったんですけど
そこでその人はもうバリ島
バリ島通で もうすっちょろいく
もう全部知っている そこで私にいろんなことを心配してアドバイスするはするはするは
そこでね 服装もいろいろ決まっているんだとかね
こういうだらしない服とか
それこの衣だったらどうでしょうかね
それちょっとわからないんだとかね
で このバリ島のヒンドゥ寺院なんかに入る場合はね
まあ誰でもあろうと何とか腰巻き巻いたり
いろいろ必要でしょうとかね
あっち入ってはいけない
こっち入ってはいけないところいろいろあるんだよとか
いろいろ言うんですね
私はまあそうです そうです聞いて
自分一人で何のことなくバリ島に飛んで
もう飛行機から降りて
そこから何のことない
ヒンドゥー文化だから
日本人のことやヨーロッパ人のことはいろいろ言われますけど
私に一言誰も何も言わない
どこでもさーっと仲間で入っちゃうし
喋るは何のこともなく
それでまたその人びっくりするんですね
なんか私が随分慣れてるような感じではないかと
すぐ仲良くなったり 一緒に何とか一緒にやったりとかね
それがやっぱり文化は同じでしょ
だからその人々はヒンドゥー教なんですけど
これ見ても同じ文化だから
もうその瞬間から仲間なんですね
名前を聞くのはあと あなたの宗教は何なの？とか聞くのは随分あと
別れる時とかね そこまで一緒に行動する
そこでこのいろいろお祭り
踊りとかある時は いろいろ座る場所とか一応決まったりする
現地の人々がいるところとか
また回ったりしてね 私は平気で自分いたいところにいてみると
誰もこちらではなくて
あんたあちら行きなさい
全然ないんですね だからそれはもうその文化的な特色だと思います
で ミャンマーに行った時は
このパスポートにハンコを押してもらったのがすごい苦労したんです
全然私のこと見ようともしない
入管の人は で もうまあ坊さんだからもう縁起のいい人だと思っちゃうんですね
だから入管のあれを行ったり来たりとか
全然何のこともない 普段厳しいでしょ
この線引いていけないというね
はっきりしてるでしょ
この境界線というのは
ミャンマーに行ったら
これ私が一応よく行く人だから
これ困っちゃうと これハンコがないと大変なことになるんだと
ハンコはビザになるんだからね
一旦行って 誰かもう車あるんだからじゃあ乗りなさいって言ったら 「
ちょっと待ってください
これパスポート見てないんですよ
あの人は」と で また戻ったんですよ
また戻って 強引にこのパスポートを私はこれハンコ押して欲しいんだよ
そう言って開けて それでハンコを押してビザを押してくれたんです
もしそのまま行っちゃったらそのままなんです
もうまた帰る時も同じくで
何のことなくそこを行っちゃえば
あんたあんたもうもうちゃんとパスポート見せないとそれないんです
でも他の人には厳しい
ものすごい厳しい そこはもう文化的なもうあれでなんか偉い
もう なんかすごい勘違い
何とか感覚は違うんですよ
そこはやっぱりインド文化系というかね
まあヒンドゥー文化系というかね
そちら辺ではもう巨大な家族なんですね
いつでも 同じで一人がヴィシュヌ信仰を信仰しているわ
もう一人はシバ神を信仰しているわと
それは構いません 弟は徹底したシバ信仰だと
兄貴が徹底したもうヴィシュヌ信仰だと
だから全部違うんですよ
神のあれも違うわ 仕切りも違うわ
やり方は違うわ あの恐れのは違うわ
ド派手に違うんですよ
全然気にしない それが
それでお父さんもしかするとそういう儀式まるっきり反対して
ヨガだけやってるかもしれません
お父さんの部屋に行ったら何もまるっきり何もない
お父さん瞑想だけしていると
息子はド派手に儀式儀礼やってるとかね
それを同じ家で行えるんですよ
そういうことが一応あるんです
そういうことだから そんなそこまで言う必要ないんですけど
だからなんで最後に名前聞くんですかと
これはやらせではないかと
と思っても これがやらせじゃなくて普通なんです
最後にびっくりさせるために
もう作品として作ったものではないかって
そこはないと思います
そこでプンノーティメアウソナマン
私の名前はプンナですと
マンターニプットーティチャパナマンサブラマチャーリージャーナティーティ
他のお坊さんたち私にマンターニプッタと呼びますよと
ファミリーネームで呼びますよだからね
そこでサーリプッタアッチャリアンアウソアブタンアウソ
なんて不思議ですかと
珍しいでしょうか
ヤタタンすたわたさわけなさんまでわさっとうささなんあじゃなんていなえわめわんあやすまたぷんねなマンターニプッテーナガンビーラガンビーラパンニャアヌマッサアヌマッサビャカタ
で なんて珍しいことですかと
こんなに有名なね こんなに素晴らしい
こんなに有名なプンナ長老に
私の質問にも一つ一つもう片っ端から明確に答えてくれて
なんてすごいですかと
サーリプッタ尊者が素直に喜ぶんです
ラーバサブラクマチャーティーナ
他のお坊さんたちにも
これはすごい大徳であると
こんなプンナマンターニプッタみたいなお坊様に会うことができて
なんて得でしょうかと
チェランドゥケーネピチェピサブラクマチャーリーアヤスマンタンプンマンターニプッタンムッドナパリハランタラベヤンダッサナヤラベユンパルーパヤサナヤテーサンピラーバテーサンピスラッダン
[笑い]そこでこのチェーランドゥカって何ですかね
えーと これの注釈はすっごい長いんですよ
チェーランドゥカってエッタ チェーラン ウッチャンってワッタン アンドゥカンってチョンバタタン
で こちら注釈書にはこのチェーランドゥカっていうのは
あの ものを頭で運ぶ場合は
この頭にちょっとクッションを入れるんですね
インドの映画とか見ると見られると思いますけど
頭の上でいっぱい荷物運ぶでしょ
その時は頭にちょっとした座布団みたいな小さな丸いやつをクッションで入れる
それを長いものをちょっと丸めて丸めて丸くして
頭の上に乗せて 例えば何かなければ自分首にかけている布でもってこうやって丸めて
頭の上に乗せて その上荷物を押せ-- 押す
置くんですよ そうするときちんとしっかり座るんです
荷物が で これがチェーランドゥカなんですけど
これって俺意味がわからないんだけど
マンターニプッタ長老はそういう風に頭に乗せて運ぶことできても大徳ですよと言ったってもね
っていうことはおそらくこういうことだと意味がわかる
プンナ長老がすごく病気になっちゃって
もう寝たきりになっちゃって
もうどうにもならん状態になったと
それで人が運ばなくちゃいけないんですね
そんな状態で会うことをできても
これは素晴らしいんだと
という意味だと思います
もう寝たきり状態になって
ほとんど喋れない状態であっても
プンナマンターニプッタ長老に会うことをできれば
それこそ大徳ですよと
そこで次にアッマーカンピラーバ
私もすごく得しましたと
アッマーカンピスラッダン
よく得しましたと イェーマヤンアヤスマンタン プンナマンターニプッタン ラバーマダッサンナエ ラバーマパイルーパーサンナエ
私にもプンナマンターニプッタ長老とお話ができたことはとてもとてもありがたいことで得をしましたと
よかったと だからサーリプッタ尊者の性格から見ると
これは全然お世辞ではなくて
純粋に喜ぶ方なんですよ
エヴァン
ウッテーアヤスマ プンナマンターニプッタ アヤスマンダサーリプッタ エタドーチャ コーナーマ アヤスマ カタンチャパナ
アヤスマンタン サブラマチャーリ ジャーナティーティ
で あなたはどなたでしょうかと聞く
それでウパティッソ コーメ アウソナーマン
私の名前はウパティッサですと
サーリプットーティチャパナマン サブラマチャーリ ジャーナティーティ
でも他の修行者たちは私にサーリプッタ サーリプッタと言うんだよと
サットゥ サットゥカッぺーナ ワタキラ ブーサーヴァケーナ サッティン マンテーマーナ ナジャーニンハ
釈尊に褒められている
釈尊に認められている
修行者に 話していたのに私は知らなかったんだよと
いわゆるお釈迦様が弟子比丘たちの中で第一人者として
智慧の第一人者として褒めている
その位に位を与えている
こんな立派な人と私はよく喋りましたと
それでも気がつかなかったんではないかと
アヤスマサーリプッタと
この人はサーリプッタ尊者だと知らなかったと
サチェーヒマヤンジャーネーヤマ
もし知ったならばアヤスマサーリプットーと
これサーリプッタ尊者だということを知ったならばエッタカンピノーナ ナッパティバーセーヤ
こんな話できないんだよと
あまりにも緊張してしまっちゃって喋れなくなるはずでしたよと
ナッパティバーセーっていうのは頭が回転してくれないという
もし知ったならば もう質問に答えるところではなかったと
それぐらいサーリプッタ尊者がすごいんです
アッチリヤンアウソ アブッタンアウソ
プンナ長老も驚くんですよ
初めて見たんだから この仏道の第一人者っていうのはそういう風な人ですかと
イメージと違うんですね
イメージだったらものすごいもう驚くほどの
でも何のことなくすごい素朴で単純で
これ不思議ですよと で
こういう風にものすごい難しい難しい質問をもうとことん次から次へと質問できるサーリプッタ尊者っていうのはものすごい珍しいんだと
で 同じことでサーリプッタ尊者に会うことをできたならば
それほど幸せですよと
またチェーランドゥケーのね
頭の上に運ぶ状態であっても
とても素晴らしいことで
私もすごい得しましたよと言うと
お互いにそういうような言葉交わして
経典は終了します しかし
問題は何でこの二人ともこんなに驚くんですかと
この質問と答えに だからこれはとてもガンビーノですよ
とっても深い意味の話し合いなんです
そこは説明しようとすると結構私も苦労します
なぜならば結構時間かかるんです
で これがこの完全にこの悟り時の修行の過程なんです
その過程は四念処経で書いてないんです
あまり書かないんです
どこにも書かないんです
たったこの経典でしか書いてないんです
であまり知ると修行の妨げになるんです
あまりあまりも知ってしまうと
知識的に知ってしまうと修行の妨げになっちゃうんですね
ですから これがこのやっている人しか知らない世界なんです
この七つは 一応みんな勉強するんだ
七つぐらい勉強してよけと
だからみんなシーラヴィスッティ
チッタヴィスッティ ディッティヴィスッティ
カンカヴィタッヌヴィスッティ
ニャーナダッッサナヴィスッティ
マッガンマガニャーナダッサーナヴィスッティ
パティパダーニャーナダッサーナヴィスッティ
ニャーナダッサーナヴィスッティと覚えているんですけどね
では何なのかというと
それは教えてくれない
どうしても教えてあげればヴィスッティマグガではもう詳しく明確に説明しています
でもそれを知ったとからてヴィスッティマグガでもそこら辺ではかなり気をつけているんです
一人で読んで理解してたまるかと
で 混乱しちゃうんです
混乱させるために書いてるわけじゃなくて
このあらゆる修行者の経験と人間っていうのは人格的に違うんだから
ヴィパッサナーの道いろいろ変わるんですよ
それどんな風に変わってもヴィスッティマグガではガイドがあります
どんな人が瞑想しても
自分にふさわしいガイドはそちらに入ってるんです
だから万人に適切なガイドですから
いろんなものあるんです
全部読んじゃうと一人の個人が修行できなくなるんです
だから専門家以外はそれは大体あまり使わない
専門家っていうのは指導する人々だから
まあその人も自分でやる場合は全部読まないし
先生から教えてもらう自分に自分にテーラーメイドしたところをね
一旦完成したら残りをさっと読んで理解できる
この七つの段階なんですね
だから仏道っていうのはまず戒律から始まるんです
まずだらしない生き方しっかりする
だから戒律守るということはもう必ずしも必要です
で といってもそんなに難しくはない
その場合でもテーラーメイドですよ
戒律っていうのは あまりにも性格悪くて
いわゆる自己管理できない
性格悪いと言ったっても自己管理できない
場合は戒律は厳しい 例えばもうほとんど食べ物には興味ない人に何か食べればいいやと思っている人にとっては
食べ物に対してごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ戒律をつけたとは何の意味もないんです
言ったって興味ないんだよと
関係ないんだよと ということになるんです
しかし食べ物を見たらつい手が行ったり
やっぱり食べたいなとかね
思ったりしちゃうと そこら辺で戒律増やさなくちゃいけない
ですから戒律でも大体はテーラーメイドですよ
その中でこのまあ在家の場合は五戒とかね
修行瞑想する場合は八戒とか十戒とかはあって
それだけで十分だというんです
そこでなぜ瞑想道場なんか作って
あるいは瞑想会なんか作ってやるかというと
この戒律できるだけオートモードで守ってもらうためなんです
音楽に目がない人がいても
もうないんだから聞けないんですね
そこで自分が落ち着いてるなという気持ちになってくる
食い物にはもうなかなか目がない人がいたっても
そんな大量にいろんな食い物は用意しておかないんです
そうすると これで我慢しなくちゃいけない
ああ なるほど 私は修行中やっていうことを気づくんですね
そうするとこの道場なんかは
戒律なんかはすぐ入った瞬間からもう守られてる
オートモードにしているんです
そこからそんなに厳しくはない
しかし 社会で生活して長い間戒律を守ってみた方が
かなり自己管理ができているはずなんです
ですから 常に五戒ぐらいは守っておきなさい
在家の人々は 出家の人々にはまた別々に戒律はありますから
それぞれ守っておきなさいと
市中生活の中で守るということは結構競争ですよ
結構チャレンジですよ
それで自己管理はできちゃう
まずこの基本的な自己管理できたところで
そこから修行を始める
次に瞑想をする 普通のサマタ瞑想
ちょっとサマタ瞑想 瞑想したことがないんだからね
呼吸瞑想やら何とかちょっとちょっと瞑想して瞑想に馴染む
瞑想に馴染む 馴染んだら禅定とかは作れますし
で 禅定作るに時間がかかるんだから
また別なプロセスがあって同時にやりましょうというね
ヴィパッサナーだけやりますという
そこは一番今主流になっているんです
サマーディ瞑想してヴィパッサナーに入ることはあまり今世の中でないんです
時間がかかる 一生かけてやらないと
でも今一生かけてくれる人っていうのは少ないんで
出家以外はね ですから
この短時間で完成するようにという
どんな人にもふさわしい
こちらもうもう仏教はもうすぐその人の体に合わせてちゃんとちゃんと服を作ってやりますからね
プロだからね 仏教はもう服を例えてくるともうテーラーとして世界一だから背が短い人が来ようか
あんまりバカでかい背が高い人がもう問題ない
もう長さを聞いて あ そう
じゃあまあこれこれでいいやというふうに作ってくれますので
いろいろヴィパッサナーのやり方
システムができているんです
とにかく ２番目はチッタヴィスッディということは瞑想に馴染む
瞑想に馴染んで集中することは習う
集中力っていうのは音楽を聞きたいなとかね
美味しいものを食べたいなと
戒律の範囲の中ででもそういう依存症あるとサマーディが生まれてこない
やっぱり俗世間はもういいや
この方がすごい楽しいと
とわかってくると集中力が生まれてくる
そこで悟ったわけじゃない
次のステージあります
そこから本格的なヴィパッサナーに入るんです
観察に入るんです サティパッターナの
四念処経の 歩く時 座る時
ご飯食べる時 寝る時 もう全部体の行為
行動を観察する 呼吸する時も観察する
体の感覚も観察していく
心の状態も観察している
だから皆様に紹介しているのはそこからなんです
いきなり あれはちょっとスピードでさっさと五戒を授けてあげて
もう何とか何とか このその時間だけででも戒律守ってくれと
戒律はないとうまくいかないんです
だから必ず瞑想する前に戒律を授けてあげる
そこで受けたばっかりだから
一応戒律は一応完成ということにしましょうと
侵すこともできないし
そういうふうな このいろいろ強引なやり方なんですけどね
で だから朝から晩まで修行すると
また午後また戒律授けてあげる
で なぜかというと まだ何か戒律破った可能性もあるし
そうするとまた瞑想が進めなくなっちゃうんです
そういう感じで 朝も午後も戒律を授けたりして
で 一応戒律を完成ということにして
チッタヴィスッディは同時にやりますので
いきなり瞑想ということで両方ヴィパッサナーやってくださいと瞑想で
そうすると瞑想とヴィパッサナー一緒やったから
まあ一緒ということで
で そこであらゆるものを観察するとディッティヴィスッディという智慧が現れてくる
ここがどういうふうに現れてくるかっていうことは
あんまり言ってわかんですよ
で なぜかというと人はそれそれなんです
だから結果だけ言うんです
うーん その前に その中にきめ細かい段階まだたくさんあります
最初に出てくるのはナーマルーパパリッチェーダニャーナという知恵なんです
えーと ナーマとルーパ
名色ですね 心と物質を区別して別々なものであると
異質なものであると はっきりわかるんです
これが体 これが心 この二つは水と油みたいなもんだよと
一緒にいたっても それで体という物質はこういう法則で動いているものだと
心というものはこういうふうに動いているものだと
これが最初のステージなんです
ナーマルーパパリッチェーダニャーナ
そこらへんこちらないんですよ
で 経典の中でもそんなに出てこない
これは言い伝えで言い伝えで来て
注釈書で残るという だから実践の世界なんです
あまり本に載るものじゃないんです
で そこでナーマルーパ別々で働くものであって
その時でもやっぱり変化していくものだと
こんなこれこうなるにも変化していくものではないかと
瞬間でも心は安定していないわ
心も瞬間瞬間変わるもんだと
まあそれしかないんだよとわかったところで
魂はなんぞやとかね もう関係なくなっちゃうんです
バカじゃないか そんな話するのは
神様が霊魂を吹いてくれたと
俺の体の中にとかね あの連中もういい加減にしなさいって気持ちになるんです
そこでディッティソッティなんです
ディッティってのはたくさんあるんだから
今神だけじゃないんですよ
例えば体心っていうのは本来至福を感じているものだぞというヒードに迫るでしょ
快楽主義とかね 飛んじゃうんです
何よこれ 何の 瞬間でも至福感じてはないでしょうにと
痛いだけではないかと
嫌な気持ちだけではないかと
ただ痛みが消えると気分がいいだけで
すぐまた気持ち悪くなるのではないかと
だから本来至福ということではなくて
その場でその場で至福感じたり
苦しみ感じたり 苛立ち感じたりするだけだと
流れていくんだと ということで
唯物論であろうか 唯識論であろうか
実体論であろうか ことごとく落ちていくんです
ところから きれいになるんですよ
もうあんなのはもう もう気にしなくていいやと
もうただのうわごとやと
人間の 気楽に生きるようになるんです
汝は神を信じますか？と聞いたっても
で まあ汝は信じても 汝はアホだから信じてもこちらには関係ないんだぞと
という状態になりますよ
神は恐れますか？というと
そんなに怖い奴ですかと
神っていうのはそんなに怖い奴ですかと
だったら逃げろよ お前も
という風に ものすごく簡単に軽々人生になるんですよ
で 普通の人々ってそういう風にもう神を馬鹿にしたり冗談言ったりするの怖がるでしょ
みんな怖がるんです それはもうこうして過程通ってないんだから
ですから そこでディッティヴィスッディという状態に達する
それ達したんだから言って全部わかったわけじゃないんですよ
やっぱりブッダが教えてるナーマルーパは無常であって
ずっと無常でいくんですよ
瞬間瞬間生滅変化するもので
それしかないんだよと
あってもまだまだ義が晴れてないんです
次にさらにヴィパッサナー瞑想ずっと続くんですよ
そうすると ああ これだからこれが現れた
これだからこれが現れたと
そうやって因果法則の方向に自動的にいくんですよ
例えば痛みを観察していく
痛み 痛み 痛み 痛み 痛みと言ったっても
やっぱり嫌だ これはと
それ嫌だと思ったことをまた観察する
それ痛みっていうのはどうせ続くもんじゃなくて
すぐ消えるでしょ 消えたら
あ 嫌な気持ちも消えちゃった
今気分がいいやと そこで
あ なるほど 痛みがあると
それが自分が逆らって嫌な気持ちになって
瞑想もやめたくなったとかね
そこで痛み消えた ただの痛み消えただけですけど
瞬間で じゃあ瞑想したくなっちゃったと
その痛みが来たらまた瞑想やめたくなるでしょとかね
そこは因果法則なんですよ
当てにならんともうその瞬間で出来事やと
そこで全体的な知恵がある
世の中そんなもんやと
私は怒れませんぞとみんな威張ったっても
その瞬間の状況だけなんですよと
もし怒れる状況生まれたら怒るでしょうと
私なんかはもう落ち着いているぞと言ったって今だけでしょうと
今落ち着いていられる状況だから落ち着いていると
別な状況であなたを混乱するんだよと
だからどんな現象でも一時的で
その条件によって現れてくるものであって
何一つも固定してないんだと
で これでカンカーヴィタルのヴィスッディなんです
でカンカーヴィタルのヴィスッディという義を一切義を晴れる
消えてしまう状態に達するためには
因果論を知り尽くさなくちゃいけない
知り尽くすと言ったっても
だから因果法則を勉強しようと思ったらこれで意味がないんです
無明はなんせやとかね
情はなんせやとやったって何の意味もないんです
これは体験でやらなくちゃいけないんです
そこをステージ通ったら
こんなのはもうたまらんと
自分がある瞬間で気分が良くて
瞑想したくてしたくて張り切っている
また秒足らないうちにやっぱりやめちゃうかなという
また根性がまた変わっちゃうし
でも自分が瞑想正しい知っているし
でもやっぱり痛くなっちゃうとやめたいし
眠くなってくると寝たくなっちゃうし
こんなのもうもうもうたまらんと
こんなあやふやな状態っていう風になってきて
やっぱりそれでマッガーマッガという状態にチャレンジするんですね
では人間どんな道を選ぶべきかと
気分次第で変えるべきかと
いくら眠くたっても やっぱり寝ちゃおうと言ったっても
これではダメやと そんなのはその瞬間の条件だけではないかと
人間っていうのはしっかりと観察して
この仏道がお釈迦様おっしゃった八正道を歩むべき
それしか道がないんだと
こんなもう嫌な状態いたって
やっぱりみんな瞬間の気分でしょ
全ての人間が だからあの人いい人
この人悪い人言えないんですよ
あんなにこの人すごく親切だから人を殴るわけじゃありませんよと言えませんよ
いくら親切でも その条件に置かれたら殴っちゃう可能性あるんだから
だから自分もそうでしょうし
だからそんな不安定な状態でいいんですかね
これいいわけじゃない
だったらさらに観察して
お釈迦様おっしゃった道を選んでやるしかないんだと
八正道 で覚悟するというか納得いくんですよ
絶対これしか道がないんだと
そこはマッガーマッガニャーナ・ダッサナというレベルなんです
そうやって自分の気分がそれなりにそれなりに変わって変わっていくんです
そこで次にまたチャレンジするんで
同じヴィパッサナー瞑想に
痛かろう 寒かろう もう眠かろうがもうるっけえかもわからん
もう死に物狂いで頑張っちゃうんです
次に そこはパティパダニャーナ・ダッサナというんです
それでもいっそでも無常に常にスーッと出会って出会って
因果法則に同じことにしか出会わないんです
それしか存在しないんだから
わしはここまで修業してるのに
まだまだ同じところにいるんではないかと
まだ嫌な不満 いろいろなできてくるんですよ
ここまでやってるのに
まだまだ同じことで膨らみやら縮みやらしびれやら
さすねんやらとかね 何がこれやとかね
すごい不安に陥ったりするんです
その順番が別なセットいろいろあるんです
そこで何一つも実況中継したいんだけど
確認したいんだけど どうせ変わるんだからね
やりきれんと 確認したって
また次の別なものでしょ
確認しなくちゃいけない
別なもの確認しなくちゃ
これどこまでやるんですかと
どこまででも同じことではないかと
そういう風にすごい精神的な何か不安な状態にも置かれますけど
でも それで諦めるんです
何か探すのは こんな状況にいるのはすごく良くないんだと
自分がなかなか抜けられない状態にいるんではないか
べったり過ぎてるんではないか
それを怖くなるんですよ
無常だと明確に知っている
すべて瞬間だと明確に知っている
何一つも当てにならんだと
人間がいるんだと言ったっても
単なる現象であると知っている
自分自分だと言ったっても
単なる現象知っているんだけど
自分がなんとか粘り続けてるんですね
こんな状態 ほど危険な状態がないんだと
もうどんな人間にも感じられないほどの恐怖感が生まれてくるんです
恐れが生まれてくるんです
これは人を殺される恐怖感よりも強いんです
その徹底した恐怖感の過ぎた悟り人です
もう嫌やと 一切は嫌ですと
何にも執着するもんじゃないやという気持ちでいた途端
パッと心がもう止まってくれるんです
道がこれということ それがアーナパナサティなんです
そこで ああ やっと落ち着いたということになるんです
で そこを四段階やりましてね
悟りも四段階ですからね
預流果とかうんうんとかね
で 預流果になるまで 今大体二十三ぐらいに分析分けてます
そのステージは で また最初からまた一来果になりたければ
また最初からやらなくちゃいけないんですよ
その時にはまたまた別々
ちょっと瞑想プロセス少々変えますけどね
また返り咲きから始まるんです
で 阿羅漢果になる場合でも同じことで
だからまあプロセスは同じヴィパッサナーだった人とそれでずっとできます
人間はやっぱり指導を受けて
ちゃんと脱線しないようにしなくちゃいけないだけで
で 預流果に悟るまではそんなに瞑想っていうのはそんなに要りません
一時的な瞑想でいいんです
で 実体論を破れるだけですからね
一来果になる場合は ちょっと瞑想の能力が必要なんです
それで欲はかなりやられますからね
二番目に三番目にも瞑想の能力が必要なんです
阿羅漢果になるためにはまあ結構世俗的な束縛あれやこれやというの全てやめてから始めなくちゃいけないんです
だから最下ではまあ成り立たないんです
阿羅漢果は 普賢果まではできます
で それはまあそれも基本的な戒律のレベルで起こることで
そこら辺まではまああまりまああまりみんな我々あまり言うとこではないんですけどね
で あまり言っちゃうと
これあまりにもレベル高くてね
私たちにはできるものじゃないってことになる
それ仏教の世界で起きたんですよ
まあベチャベチャベチャベチャお坊さんたちがね
説法して説法して あまりにも説法しすぎちゃって
こんなのは人間にできるもんじゃないんだよという風に気持ちになっちゃうんですよ
それであまり瞑想する気にならなくなっちゃうとか
それ逆効果でしょうし
最近はスリランカのお坊さんたちの説法をちょっとずつ調べたんですけど
最近また元に戻っているみたいですね
またあの難しい教えはもう皆の鼻の先に持ってこようと
若いお坊さんたちいろいろ頑張っているみたい 「
今すぐ取らなきゃ何の意味もないんだよ」と
このバカ者という態度で説法するお坊さんもただラジオで聞いていたんです
普通は大体信者さんを褒めて説法するんです
で 私は私だけだよと せっかく聞いてくるのに
人をけなすのもなと思ってたんですけど
ラジオで説法一部だけ聞いたんですけど
もう結構けなすんですね
聞いてる人々 すごく丁寧に質問するんですよ
で 今言ったこともう分かったでしょ？これはどうでしょうこと言うと相手が答えるんです
ほら あんた全然分かってないんではないかと
だから言ってるんではないかと
聞きなりもう落としちゃうんです
あ この人はかなり真剣だなと
このお坊さんはと と思ったんですね
だからなんか最近の傾向はそういう風にもう一度あの悟りの境地をね
みんなの手に入るようにしてあげようということで
まあそうなるとそんなにもこのきめ細かい専門的な説明はしません
専門的な説明するともうできなくなっちゃうという
まあ一応その七つの段階はそういう段階で
で その中でも微妙な段階いろいろあります
悟りというのは確実に心に起こる変化だから
で 何も取らんそうと心が決めるんだから
何も取らんそうと言ったところで心を証明するんですよ
自殺と同じなんです 私は幸せになるために呼吸をやめますよと言ったら
それだけでその人死んじゃうでしょうに
それぐらいのものなんです
だから心というのは認識する
依存するという機能は心であって
依存しないよと思ったら心の存在もそこで消えちゃうんです
だからアヌパーダ・パリニルバーナということになるんです
解脱は そこはまあまあそう普通理解難しいかもしれませんですけど
一応そのここでしか この経典でしか明確に出てこないし
で 本気になって説明すると結構大変です
とりあえずそれぐらいの理解でまあ納得するしかないと思います
ここら辺は大乗の世界でも教えられていないんです
おさらば漢文でもこの経典のあの
訳はない  え？ない？ 訳はないかもしれません
まあ影の経典いろいろあるかもしれませんですけどね
だから本物の経典だから捨てるということにあっても理解はできん
ですから みんなこの何が段階やとかね
一発で悟るんではないか
いろいろ言うんですけど
そんなある全て段階でしょうに
米をまいて一発で稲刈りとかね
もうそいつらもういい加減因果法則
全て段階ですからね 全て順番だから
今遅くなったんだから一発で家にいるそうと言ったっても
そんな成り立たんでしょうに
玄関から出ていてちゃんといかないと
だからこのあまりも宗教は迷信になっちゃって
妄想になっちゃって チベット仏教になってしまう
ちゃうともう仏教で全くなくなっちゃうんですよ
だからこのあまり大乗世界ではここら辺はないということはよく見えます
ところがテーラワーダの世界でもそんなに表に出さないんですね
それはテーラワーダの教えか大乗の教えではなくて
これは人間にとってはとても大事な
唯一の大事な悟りの方法であって
解脱への方法であって
だからもうものすごい大事に守らなくてはいけないし
実践者にのみわかるようにしてあげなくちゃいけないんですね
もし実践者がなくなっちゃうと
やっぱりそれではマニュアル書いておかないと困るんだから
ちゃんとマニュアルとして残っている
一応ヴィスッディ ヴィスッディ
ヴィスッディという清浄境地
ヴィスッディっていうのはね purity state
of purity 綺麗になった状態
だから綺麗になるってことは何か落として綺麗になる
何か落として綺麗になるという七段階の落とす
落としていくんです 最後に心から落としてるんだから
そこで解脱っていうのは心も止まってもらうという
いわゆる最後の車から降りて宮殿に入ると
車と宮殿とは何の関係もなくなっちゃうんです
ということです 話は以上です
その経典の中でも お釈迦様は完全に仏道はあの十項目でね
語ったでしょ あの最初に
あれはどちらかというとすごく理解しやすくて
柔らかくて優しくて なるほどなというね
感じになりますね 一般の人にも一部だけでもやってみようかなとかね
気持ちにはなる でもそこら辺では随分ないんですよ
例えばニャーナ・ダッサン
それどうしましょうかとかね
そこになってくると お釈迦様もじゃあ賢者に付き合いなさいよというふうにも入れちゃいますからね
マーガンディに言ったように
それ教えてちょうだい
じゃあだったらあんた行って勉強しなさいと
それは時間かかる でもお釈迦様がもう偉大な師として誰にでも理解できるように
すごく優しく ああ何か分かるなという気分にさせるんですよ
これならできるんじゃないかなという気分にどうしてもお釈迦様はさせるんです
それでではやらせようと思ってサーリプッタ尊者のところにマンターニプッタ長老のところに行ったところで
まあシーラ・ヴィスッディから始まりますから
そこからかなり[笑い]厳しい世界が待ってるんです
だから役柄はちゃんと分かれてるんです
お釈迦様は見事に奨励するんですよ
邪教 自分の教えこそ唯一絶対正しいと来ている人も出家してまっちゃいますから
で そこからの訓練というのは
自分の弟子たちに任せてると思うんです
どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございました